Hello, hello, hello, hello.
I don't know how you guys might be like...
What the fuck?
It's okay, I used R1.
One down, one down, one to go.
It already started.
I mean, what's going on here?
Okay, so like, we're told we can only have two F-bombs.
And bombs.
And the whole stream!
You
know, it was just natural.
I couldn't help it, man.
It's been a week since I streamed, I couldn't help it.
I need to get it out.
So it's not like two out of each of us, it's two in the entire stream from all of us here.
And you're like, what do you mean by all of us?
It's just you and me.
No, we actually have a mysterious third person here with us today.
What?
That's me.
Hi, I'm a mysterious person.
I'm Fulham, to those of you who don't know me.
I also don't have a VTuber model because I'm not a VTuber.
I'm the Minecraft guy.
CaptainSparklez?
He's not CaptainSparklez.
I wish, I wish.
Oh my god, it's the CaptainSparklez, but British.
British CaptainSparklez.
Do you want to do an introduction, Fulham?
I mean, dude, I think you guys introduced me well enough.
I can be a British CaptainSparklez if you need me.
I think as far as I know, my aim is to help you guys know what's going on in the game.
Yes, so he is our Minecraft analysis.
Analysis expert.
Yeah, yeah, the analysis expert.
Because we are here, Min and I are here, to cast a Minecraft tournament.
Yeah!
I guess you couldn't tell that it's you.
It's not just any kind of Minecraft tournament.
Oh, no, no, no.
It is a MOBA Minecraft tournament, which Min and I have zero knowledge.
We were like, wait, today, we're like, wait, this is a MOBA?
And then I was like, wait, I thought you knew about MOBA.
It's like, no, I don't play.
I didn't say it, I didn't say it, we still have our one.
It's okay, we still got one left, we still got one left.
I didn't say it.
No, I didn't say it.
I don't freaking play League.
League!
It's great, because none of us play League, and none of us play any MOBAs.
So we're all gonna have to learn as we go.
We're gonna learn today.
I've played Minecraft, though.
Actually, Doki and I, we recently spedrun beating the game.
Oh, yeah, beating.
On hardcore.
Yeah, we totally beat it.
See, this is what I like to hear.
That's my whole thing.
That's what I do every day.
I do the whole speedrunning thing.
We did it under 24 hours, too.
Dude, that is faster than some people I know.
Congratulations.
What's your PB?
Okay, okay, you're asking...
Alright, I mean, 10 minutes, 40 seconds.
But let's, you know, 10 minutes, 24 hours, that's the same thing, man.
It's, yeah, exactly.
We were in hardcore, I think that accounts for like, you know, minus...
That actually, yeah.
Minus, like, 50 hours or something.
Exactly.
So I think you guys beat me, to be fair.
I feel like we are the professionals at this point.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, so, yeah, so we're here to cast...
It was actually crazy.
They, like, asked me to cast a Minecraft tournament.
And they're wondering, oh, hey, dude, you know anyone you could bring over?
And I was like, I think Mint's a good co-caster.
And then Mint actually researched more about this than I did.
I didn't research.
They literally sent us documents that you chose not to read.
I got food poisoning yesterday.
I have my excuse.
I got food pois... Okay, I think everyone knows I'm in Japan.
Everyone knows now, anyway.
I mean, my times... The times I've been commuting is very obvious.
How do I get food poisoning in Japan?
Like, I don't...
It's the MOBA part.
MOBA part.
Oh my gosh, look at this map.
It's kind of crazy.
This map is pretty cool.
I was told that the maps have names.
I'm going to be real with you.
I don't remember what they are.
So I'm going to find out right now.
We are in Round 1 Block City.
That is a really imaginative name for a city full of blocks, I think.
I wish I was shitting you, but that's, like, the real name.
That's so good.
It's restarting.
It's restarting again.
Okay, we're back.
Maybe we're not back, actually.
We hear audio from their game.
Oh, there's the golden rabbit.
What is that?
Oh, it's called Block City.
Round 1 is in Block City.
That's what I said.
Oh, I thought you were lying.
We're back to CaptainSparklez.
Oh, yeah.
What's the lore?
You said you read the lore.
Well, hold on.
I believe the first match is TeamSparklez versus TeamHannah.
Uh-huh.
Now, I know all of the people in this event.
Because I'm in the Minecraft scene.
I'm in the space.
I know the teams, which is kind of cool.
You know them?
So, some people know that I'm actually not at my home PC right now.
I'm in the house of someone who's playing on CaptainSparklez's team.
I think he's in TeamSparklez right now.
I'll pay you $50 to sabotage.
Do you want me to go unplug his internet?
That would be really good.
Go unplug his monitor right now.
Put some peanut butter on it.
Unleash a rat to go and do the dirty work for you.
That's weird.
There is one really long cable running through the room.
But I think it's the internet cable.
Do it.
There's some scissors over there.
They won't know.
It's not like there's evidence right here.
I'm also connected to that internet though.
So, I would just vanish at the same time.
That would be for a worthy cause.
Imagine the content.
Imagine the drama in the content.
If I leave at some random point...
If you unplug this guy's internet, everybody will know.
Drama creates content.
I learned about that last week.
Let's save that for another time.
I'm going to read some things from the document.
I'm going to read the objective of the game.
That's helpful to know, I think.
I think the objective is going to be super important.
Oh, there's Hannah!
They're bowing to each other.
So polite.
Good game.
The objective is to eliminate the enemy's dragon.
Each team has their own little ender dragon.
It's actually kind of cute.
It's surrounded by end crystals.
It's kind of like the ender dragon fight.
Where you have to destroy the crystals.
Before the dragon can be killed.
And they also have withers.
I don't know what that's about.
Oh, so the dragon is the end point.
Like League.
The dragon is the giant crystal in League.
I don't play League, but I've seen it.
With your own two eyes?
Yeah, with my own two eyes.
I've seen one or two League games in my life.
Oh, it's the Nexus!
Oh my god.
One of the moderators are like yelling at me.
Be like, it's the Nexus!
It's called the Nexus, Doki.
You goddamn nerd.
I'm sorry.
Mint didn't know what it was either.
I didn't claim to know.
You did.
I've seen a League game or two in my day.
Like one or two.
How am I supposed to know the names?
I don't know either.
That's why we are the professional casters for this tournament.
Go on with the rules.
There's five rounds.
Each round will take place in a different map.
Which is kind of cool.
Um...
Oh, there's like...
There's like...
There's different players.
So each player is going to start at their house base.
And then they're going to pick a character.
Oh, so that's where they're choosing the character.
Wait, oh yeah, you were telling me...
Apparently, each of these...
There's like characters with actual lore written about them.
Yeah, it's kind of intricate.
Like, we have...
Sir Block.
I need to hear about the granny again, please.
Because there's this granny.
I want to know someone that's playing as the granny in this game.
We have Granny Gooddrop.
Age 77.
She is recognizably an alien-like slimy yet wholesome grandma character.
She plays for the kinship.
But some people play for the thrill.
Which I was like, hag love.
Hag love.
I do.
That's the VTuber hive mind going on there.
Yeah, they're like, finally some good content.
Nah.
But they have like ultimate abilities.
So basically there's mobs in the game as well that they can kill to get money.
And then they can buy like armor or upgrades.
Yeah.
So it's just basically like farming creep and league and deadlock.
You know so much.
You know so much about this.
I play deadlock.
I play deadlock, which is sort of like league, but like shooter.
I mean, I feel like this game is more like deadlock than league.
Actually, this is actually a lot more like deadlock than league.
Wow.
I never took you as a league player, Doki Bird.
No, I didn't like deadlock.
Oh, so you like league.
She said she didn't like deadlock, everybody.
She liked league.
No, no, no.
That's what I'm hearing.
I've never watched Arcane because I'm scared it's going to make me like league.
That's the same reason I've not watched it either.
Because I do not want to like league yet.
Doki, oh my god, you have to watch Arcane, it's so good.
And I was like, no.
That's a legitimate thing you'd say.
I'm afraid that I'll actually like league if I watch Arcane.
And I refuse to give league my time.
All I know is that it takes a really long time to play.
Like, you sit there for 12 hours and then you've gained like three elo.
It's like 40 minutes to one hour per game.
And then if you're losing, the team will hold you hostage.
Because you can't quit, you can't surrender, but you have to have the whole team wanting to surrender.
And there's always going to be one asshole that's not going to let you surrender.
Like, my whole thing is doing things quickly.
Like, I want to speedrun, so like 10 minutes, great, cool, yeah, awesome.
Like, giving me an hour long game?
Dude, I can't handle that.
Luckily, I don't think these games are an hour.
That's why this is better, because I'm pretty sure we're not going to be held hostage for an hour.
And it's Minecraft!
20-30 minutes at most.
Wait, how long have you been speedrunning for?
Yeah.
This has been my thing for like four years, roughly.
So, I mean, yeah.
Are you on any records?
I used to have top 10 worldwide, which was pretty good.
And then I've slowly kind of realized that I don't have the time to put into...
Dude, some of these people spend all day doing it, and I do not have that.
I don't have that kind of capacity in me anymore.
What do you do then?
Dude, I'm getting old.
You're a speedrunner.
What do you do if you're not speedrunning?
Well, like, stream.
Some of these people do it offline and stuff, man.
Oh!
That's like me when I play Rank.
I get it.
I get that.
Yeah.
You actually have a life outside of streaming.
That's crazy.
Hey, I don't want to say that I'm at a friend's house right now doing this commentary, but hey, we were at a birthday party.
Wait, why are you at your friend's house?
Oh, it was a birthday party?
What?
Shit, sorry.
Doki.
It's okay.
We made it 30 minutes.
That's a good amount.
I had 30 minutes of it being live.
It's been a week, guys.
I haven't streamed in a week.
I have this all built up.
Anyway, I was going to say, your friend just got out of a birthday party and now he's here playing Minecraft tournament?
Damn, what a griney.
We've gone from a birthday party to do this.
I'm commentating in his living room, he's in his studio playing right now, and then as soon as we're done, we're going back out.
We're going straight back out to the bar that our friends are at.
Oh, wait, so you're going to another party?
Yeah.
Wait, so the birthday party isn't even over?
Nope.
Wait, you should pre-game here.
Yeah, this is a break.
This is a break.
You should pre-game, grab some alcohol.
Oh, hey, that's us.
Wait, I can't believe it.
The party's not even over and your friend is here.
Dude, both of us have our priorities, right?
We have to go and see our friends.
We have to say, like, happy birthday, man.
But I'm going to be so honest with you, in two hours time, I'm leaving and we're going to go play Minecraft.
And then we'll come back.
It's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, did you throw a Minecraft-themed birthday party?
Oh, dude, I wish.
Literally on branding.
It would have been so good.
As Minecrafters, you don't even throw a Minecraft party?
Like, what's the point?
Maybe we'll find the most Minecraft-y thing in his house and just take it.
Take it.
You could literally just go to Walmart and buy something.
Is there a Walmart in...
There is.
There is?
It's under a different name, yeah.
But, I mean, it is nearly...
It's like 9.30pm.
So, I think we're going to be...
I think most of the stores are closed.
I'm pretty sure Minecraft stuff is, like, everywhere, though.
You could literally go to a convenience store and find Minecraft, right?
There's bound to be a Minecraft t-shirt somewhere.
Yeah, like, I'm just going to say, like, there has to be Minecraft somewhere.
And you know what?
If your friend wins, you know, the prize money at first place is $25,000 for the whole team.
25k?
I think, you know, drinks would be on them, probably.
Oh, we're watching him right now.
This is the friend that I'm next to.
Should I run?
Should I run into his room?
Go, go, go!
Show up at his camp right now.
See if he's actually... if he's lying to us or not.
He could be like, I know this guy, and he actually doesn't know.
So my chat was like, dox yourself now.
Is this conflict of interest?
I did it, I did it.
Yeah, we did.
Yeah, we saw you, we saw you.
Yeah, our chat was like, oh my god, face reveal.
Is this a real British Captain Sparkles?
That's me, that's me.
Oh my god.
My chat was like, is that Captain Sparkles?
Why is this guy throwing like...
Captain Sparkles is like throwing...
what is he doing?
He's got like a little tail.
Oh my god, ERC sir, subscribe for two months.
Thanks for the subscription.
I think we're gonna be starting the game soon-ish.
Wait, how many teams are competing Mint?
That's a great question.
Okay, I'll take the answer if you need it.
We've got eight teams.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
We've got eight teams, and we split them off into two groups of four.
So those four will play against each other.
Between four players?
That's a lot.
There's five on each team though.
Five players on each team.
We have two groups of four teams, and they play against each other once, and we kind of get a seeding based on that.
So the top teams in the group will go onto a bracket, and the bottom teams will go onto a loser's bracket sort of thing.
And then we'll find out who comes first, second, third, fourth.
What we'll be doing is following the top teams the whole way through pretty much, as far as I know.
The back end staff are working hard to bring us the most interesting games as far as I know.
I'm sure they're not going to show us sixth place versus eighth place.
You know what I mean?
They're going to show us first and second.
But every team places they get a prize money, so that's nice.
It doesn't matter.
Even your last place, you get money in the end.
And then Minted already got paid, so we're fine.
Hey, we all know why you're here.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
I'm here for the games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're here also for the games, too.
Oh, yeah.
I'm here to watch the thrills.
Actually, I'm curious to know what MOBA Minecraft is like.
Yeah, me too, honestly.
I want to see how they actually run the whole thing.
I'm glad I don't have to play.
It's actually crazy how much you can customize Minecraft in general for random games and stuff.
Have you ever played anything other than vanilla?
Yeah, I have.
Like, separate game modes and stuff?
Special game modes?
I played Sonic the Hedgehog.
The official Sonic?
Yeah, I played the official Sonic.
I played the official Sonic.
I was thinking about, like, Bed Wars or stuff like that.
Or, like, what was it called?
The Minecraft Civilization.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Fulham, would you jump for the beef?
Oh, my god.
I would jump.
I would 100% jump for the beef, and I would 100% miss and fall.
Dude, I...
Yeah, you're a professional.
I'm professionally bad.
Whoa, on stream?
It's okay.
If I bully myself, it means my chat can't bully me.
So, you know, if you think about it, it's kind of small.
No, they definitely can.
Encourages them.
You hear that, chat?
Everybody, listen up.
If I bully myself, you can't bully me.
They're like, oh, my god, finally, we can let it loose.
Oh, don't worry.
They already do.
They know who they are.
It's fine.
Oh, look, they're picking the characters.
Oh, my god, there's a rabbit boy?
Dude, that's awesome.
Did you see her?
She was like the green...
Oh, my god.
I see her.
She's green.
Who the heck is the slimy... the bunny boy there?
Let me see.
Hold on, I have the characters pulled up.
Slime bag.
Guys, the reason why I'm not looking at it is because I only have one monitor, which is my laptop, so I can't tab.
I can't tab in and out.
Okay, you found it?
Yeah, rabbit person, well known for his movement speed.
Okay, the name is Banjax.
I don't know who Banjax is.
Okay, I was gonna be like rabbit person.
Rabbit person would be crazy though, you're right.
So they have like ultimate abilities and stuff like throughout the game.
And obviously it kind of depends on the person you choose.
And the rabbit has rabbit's foot, which means they get like quicker...
like they get speed, which is cool.
Oh!
And then their ultimate is bunny hop, which lets them like jump really high.
The lore?
Extremely impulsive and high energy.
Banjax is well known for tauntingly leaping around his allies before eagerly leaping into the battlefield, often before his allies are ready.
Thanks.
Thank you for that lore.
But what's his age?
27?
He's 27?
Yeah, like Uncle Slimehack gets his age and like profession and everything.
And then rabbit person is like he likes to jump.
I'm just a rabbit.
I mean, there's Daedra.
Daedra is 18... or 1,862 years old.
Okay, what... yeah.
And what else about him?
I like how someone's like, is he single though?
Calm down, you guys.
That should be in the lore.
Actually, there should be like a relationship.
Taken, it's complicated.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta know.
Two of these people are children of like one another.
One of them is the child of one, right?
Wait, really?
Which one?
Angel and Axel.
So Angel is the child of Axel.
Are they both angels?
So one of them is a DPS and one of them is a healer.
The healer is the kid of the DPS.
Oh no.
Angel's a minotaur.
Oh.
Wait, is Angel the child or the...
Well, they're both minotaurs, yeah, look.
Less intimidating minotaur.
The less intimidating one is the child, according to the synopsis.
Which one is it?
Okay, but Daedra is a cowgirl demon, so I think that is relative.
Oh!
I think we might be starting.
Are we starting?
Oh my gosh.
Oh I see it.
One is a white cow, the other one is a brown cow.
Brown cow.
Yeah, see look at the left.
Oh I see.
No one is playing slimehag.
Dude.
There is already a meta.
In MCL there is already a meta.
There is already a meta This game just started!
They've done this before, apparently they've added new characters and so that's the new tournament.
I thought it was like they were playing this for the very first time, but I guess like they've trained for it and everything.
I think that there's like new maps and new characters, but this is a recurring thing, yeah.
Look, they're going around, they're killing the mobs, getting their money.
Guys, you can play MOBA League right now.
Kill that bat, kill that bat.
Oh, never mind, not enough money.
I was going to say MOBA craft, I was going to say league is already MOBA.
MOBA craft is good, I like that.
MOBA craft is great, yeah.
Oh wait, that's the nexus, the dragon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we're seeing these guys click very quickly and that is because we're using a combat system that's well known to be in an older version of Minecraft.
So, you guys have played Minecraft recently, right?
If you swing at a mob or whatever, you have to wait between your swings to charge them back up.
Back when Minecraft was a little bit in its earlier days, you can just click as much as you want and that's what we're using in this version.
You can see that CBK is just spam clicking away and gets the kill there.
Oh wait, someone died already.
Who died?
There is a respawn timer.
The more they die, the higher it gets.
So, at first it's 10 seconds and then when they respawn it'll be...
15 seconds, whatever.
Wait, is CaptainSparklez's team winning with that first kill?
That first kill might be helpful.
I actually don't know how beneficial a kill is really early on because look at the bottom of CaptainSparklez's screen.
We've got coins and mana, I think.
I think that's mana.
I'm not sure.
But then they end up spending these things on these upgrades.
Oh my god, there's a piggy bank!
Get your money, CaptainSparklez!
Get your money!
Come on, go get rich!
Look at him go!
Look at him farm the creep!
The best pirate bot in every MOBA.
I wonder if there's any secrets and stuff that you can find.
Big mobs for big money.
You can get inside a building or something and hit some crazy clip into a wall.
That's what I'd be looking for right now.
Make an invincible jump.
Exploring the map instead of doing the objective?
That's crazy.
Oh, we gotta fight!
Oh, they're fighting!
He was just dodging!
Oh no, it's one against two.
He was not gonna win that.
He got cornered.
That's one to one.
Looks like one kill each, right?
Oh, but there is another death on the other team.
Maybe we missed the death there.
I mean, it's very early on in the game.
I don't wanna make any predictions here.
I was gonna be like, oh, there's still three minutes left of the game.
I was like, that's a short game.
I realized I was counting up.
I was gonna be like, there's three minutes left?
That's crazy!
Are all these games going on simultaneously or is it like...
Yeah, exactly.
So we have like four games running at the same time and right now we're gonna watch one.
I think it's definitely, in my opinion, probably two of the best teams out of the group facing off against each other.
Wait, really?
Which team has Feinberg?
How do we know Feinberg?
Hello?
Cause I saw you was in the game.
How do you guys know Feinberg?
Well, I know Feinberg.
Oh, I don't know.
I had him on my team before and everybody was like, Feinberg has one of the top, the most records for any Minecraft tournament.
He's a good friend of mine and I love that everyone knows him.
He is a really, really lovely guy.
Is he that good of a friend?
Would he lend you $100?
Yeah, would he lend you $100?
If you were dangling from the cliff and then like, he had to he was in the middle of completing a number one Minecraft record, would he let you die or save you?
It's like if he completes the record, he'll be like number one in the world or he saves you.
Would he let you die?
I think he might save me because he's already number one.
He might save you.
There's definitely a might.
There's definitely like a 50-50 there.
I have to get lucky.
It's not even like 80 or 90.
Oh no, no, no.
Definitely 50-50.
It really depends because if everything's going right and that's the run, he's not looking away.
He's not looking away.
Even when you're like screaming at him.
100%.
He's totally locked in if that's the case.
Oh, they backed off for now.
Tactical retreat.
How long do these games usually last for?
Now that is a question I won't be able to tell you.
I think it's probably around 20 minutes, maybe 25 minutes.
That's like half of a League game.
That's already better than League.
People get to kill there.
So it does say...
But then dies in the retake.
Yeah, I mean like...
He was already low.
Oh, the Minecraft music popped in.
That scared me.
We're so chill.
It becomes so much more relaxed.
Even though we see all these people fighting.
They're all dying to each other.
But look at this Minecraft music.
It's almost like piano jump scare.
Now, something that's really interesting.
I think like...
CaptainSparklez right now isn't spending his cash, right?
He's got 350 bucks just sitting there.
And I think you can spend those on upgrades for like the team.
Oh, is this like the mid boss?
It might well be.
It looks like it's towards the middle of the map.
I guess this is going to give one team a huge advantage.
It looks like Red is taking it out.
It's right smack dab in the middle.
I wonder if the mid boss regens.
Because I know like in Deadlock the mid boss regens if you don't hit it hit it again.
Oh dude, look at the... It's got a different texture in the game.
Oh no!
Yeah, wait, why does that team have a different texture for their stats?
It shows up as a pot of gold for the other people.
It kind of makes sense.
Yeah, I was going to be like, wait, that's weird.
I guess like the different teams, it looks different.
Maybe so.
I mean, oh my god, they're so close to...
Wait, the Nexus is so close.
The Ender Dragon is so close to them.
I didn't realize it was that close.
Look out below!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh wow!
Oh wow, and it's dead!
It looks like Team Red was able to kill that, so I think that's CaptainSparklez's team was able to get whatever bonus you get.
I assume not some coins or some mana though.
It should be money because it's pot of gold.
Look out below!
I was like, what the heck was that?
What's going on here when they go into the wall?
I think they were just healing.
They were trying to hide and heal.
It looks like maybe that's a sudden death timer right underneath.
That's counting down here.
Sudden death?
Oh my god.
Dates are high!
The 20 minutes was probably a pretty good guess.
I think it's around about 20 minutes estimated.
Yeah, so I guess if they don't win the game within 20 minutes, it's like you just have one life left.
It does say that the matches have a 40 minute timer.
Oh, 40?
Well, we are a tiny bit behind schedule.
So maybe there's like a...
Maybe they're just like, nope, nevermind.
Oh!
It could be the slime respawn timer.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, possibly.
But it looks like a little skull.
That's true.
I mean, it does look... yeah.
Looks more ominous.
Yeah, we'll see in 9 minutes what it really is.
Someone go straight to the dragon.
No one's protecting it.
What if they just flank and just go straight there?
I'm sure these guys are screaming at each other in coal.
Going like, oh, we need to go left!
We need to go right!
We need to do this!
Each dragon does have the withers protecting it too, though.
That's true.
One person, I think, would be kind of...
We'll die.
That guy's so low.
His HP is so low right now.
Heal!
Oh, you can recall and go straight home.
That's smart.
That must be what they're doing then.
Yeah, so you can go back and buy items and heal and stuff.
Interesting.
And you can always protect yourself as well and just get out of situations.
I hope we get to watch someone play slime hag.
I just want to see slime hag.
Justice for slime hag.
Make her a meta.
Make her a meta again.
Again?
As if she were before.
Looks like Shatter is close to the red base here and he's getting a few kills.
He's got two kills here.
That was a good advancement.
I think that's like the first damage we've seen on any of the withers on the outside.
Oh wait, they shot the wither?
She was so far.
I think it might have literally been one hit.
So I don't think it matters that much.
But it's more than the other team have done so far.
The one hit wonder.
As long as the other team never touches the wither, they win.
Yeah, real.
It's just that easy.
Yeah, pretty much.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's a giant team fight right now.
What the heck was that?
Was that an ultimate line again?
Oh my gosh, look at the iron golem.
He's like...
Oh my god, look at them all advance.
There's four of the red team.
Four of the red team are pushing in right now.
Oh my god, they're going in.
They're going in.
The withers are fighting back.
So much of ASMR jumpscares.
I know.
Oh my god.
You want to play right now.
Wait, maybe that's the mom.
Wasn't there like a mom character here or a child?
That was blue's team, right?
That went in?
Yeah, no.
Red went in, but blue just defended their base.
You can see at the top, they've got health bars.
And the wither for blue is already at half health.
So if red go back in, that could be a big exploit for red team.
But the blue team did get a little bit of damage on the red wither as well.
And blue don't have to respawn now because it looks like red are on the defense.
Thank god for our Minecraft analysis, guys.
I know.
I would have definitely not registered on any of that.
I like the just pit a fire.
You can spawn there.
Oh, good shot!
That was such a good shot!
That was, yeah.
What a shot from that guy.
Whoever that guy was.
Oh, we got the Minecraft music back.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, they're back!
Red tower under attack!
Oh my god, wait.
They're doing big damage on that wither.
Yeah, that one wither.
They did protect it, but that one is low now.
Oh yeah, they have to retreat because all of them are coming back now.
This Minecraft music makes it so much more dramatic.
It's like calming me down.
What even are those blocks?
Those red blocks?
Those are spawns, so they're spawning like little mobs that they can attack for money and stuff.
I'm learning, see?
I'm learning as we go.
I think if we were in this I think we'd be winning, just saying.
I think so too, 100%.
As long as they give us like, you know, plus 500% HP and like plus 100% damage, yeah, we'd definitely win this.
I need like the wither skull effect where if you...
If I tap them once they lose all their heart.
Just make us giant ender dragons too and we can fly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, the caster buff right there.
Give me a card.
Give me a card and run people over.
That should be the final match.
The final team has to defeat the casters to win my game.
Whoa, the voice said red tower under attack.
Oh my god, the red tower's HP is gone.
First wither down!
Wait, why are we watching the fight?
We can't see it, please show us the face.
Show us the face.
Oh, okay, red was able to defend it.
Oh, now they're running away.
But the wither's down, so they're down to the crystal now.
No, they still have two more withers.
Yeah, they still have two more.
Everybody has three.
Do you have to kill all of the withers before you can go to the crystal?
I believe so.
I guess the crystals are closest to the wither, you know?
If you're trying to get for the other crystal.
I assume each wither is guarding their own crystal.
Yeah.
Oh my god, this one guy, he's like, let me solo him.
That one guy's just soloing.
He's almost got the wither down.
He's got it!
Where's his team?
Where's the team?
They just let him solo it.
His team are all dead, it looks like.
Red really pushed up on the blue crystals, but he was just left on his own.
He was able to solo out a whole wither.
Tactical retreat.
Getting the shots.
Now, Shatt is well known to be a really strong PvPer, so...
But, he's able to be taken down by two.
That helps.
No matter how good you are, 1v2.
1v1 him!
That's not fair!
Where is the integrity here?
He had performance anxiety.
He knew he was on the screen.
They got one guy.
All of team blue have their ults pretty much.
They are all fully charged pretty much.
They are trying to go back in.
I think if they did like a charged attack...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Who gets the kill?
I think one more wither.
They could push.
Just sneak in like that other guy.
I feel like I'm going to have to heavy defend now though, because they are so behind of everything.
Dude, he's pushing again.
Shatt is the only one at the base.
He's able to get more damage.
Look!
He's the only one here.
Okay, now he's being defended.
These guys got to watch out.
He already got like one third.
He already got a little bit of it.
Oh my god, they let him live?
He just runs away.
They just let him run away?
I like how people are like, why is Mint blue in color instead of mint?
This is her.
When she plays Minecraft, she turns blue.
This is me locked in.
Yeah.
It's like, what flavor of mint are you right now?
I'm...
Winter...no.
Winter Breeze!
Spearmint?
No, that's too green.
Wait, they already got the crystal!
Oh my god!
Dude, look at all the blue teams!
Look at blue team's health as well!
I think that's final death.
I think that's like the final.
When it gets like close to the end time.
Maybe, maybe that'll start taking more and more damage.
Maybe.
Yeah, they lowered the health.
I'm going to go shop real quick.
In the middle of a fight?
Quick intermission.
Blue crystal eliminated.
Wait, that's...
Oh my god, wait, they're going to blue...
Red team's going to win because of the timer.
It says alive though.
Yeah, but like because like the timer going down all the crystals and wither took damage, so like red has like an advantage there.
Oh, the pot of gold is back again.
Yeah, if you don't get it done in time.
Yeah.
Because it's like blue team worked so hard lowering red, like actually no, not blue team, that one guy worked so hard.
That's true, that's true.
There's a monkey in the tree!
Get him out of the tree!
Red tower is under attack.
Not the monkey!
What's he doing?
Where's his family?
Help him!
Red tower is gone.
There's only two crystals left for red.
There's only two crystals.
And they're really low, I think.
Red crystal dead.
There's only one left.
And the dragon!
Blue are going to take the win here and we're not going to be able to see it.
But it's just one guy.
It's just one guy!
It is!
They defended it just.
Just one guy!
They're all one guy!
Their main tower is on like 30% health.
This is...
Red team needs something crazy here.
They literally just have to send one guy over it.
They have two members down too.
So it's like...
That's true.
How did that one guy kill two?
There it is!
Two!
One guy!
Anna's team takes the win!
Being honest, it pretty much was a one man mission there for Shata.
He was able to take out so many towers and crystals.
That's crazy.
He actually took down the dragon himself too.
MVP.
MVP one guy.
That's crazy.
The fact that like...
Almost like...
Three people from Kat and Sparkle's team had to defend themselves against that guy.
That's crazy to see.
I know that he's a super strong player but...
I'm surprised he was able to do that much.
Because these guys...
Red's no slouch team here.
I'm not expecting them to get completely whupped.
The middle pot of gold, right?
Yeah, Red team won the pot of gold and everything.
Wait, who was the one guy?
Was it Shata?
Shata, yeah, in the bottom right.
Was it Rabbit Boy?
It's Rabbit Boy!
He was so fast.
Maybe it is.
Look, he's able to just jump around really quick.
Look down below!
Oh my god, there he is.
There's their team.
There we go.
I honestly thought Red could make a really good comeback.
Especially when they got all of that damage from the team.
At one point, it was really any person's game.
They started with the damage too.
They started really well.
Yeah, they got the first one but...
Literally, Shata was able to take out a whole crystal on his own.
I don't know how.
He took down two withers and a crystal.
And I think the dragon too.
For real, right?
There was just one person on the dragon for real.
He took down the majority of the dragon.
And he let him live.
I was so surprised.
He just ran away.
I was like, whoa, okay.
These replays are really sick, actually.
I'm so glad that we're able to see these back really quickly.
I know that's difficult.
Oh, there he is!
They killed him!
There he is, bang!
He literally killed him before his final breath!
Did you see that?
He killed the dragon before he died!
Oh my god.
What a hero.
That was crazy.
That was a crazy first game to watch.
Our next game up...
I think we still have one match going.
Which is...
Team 5UP and Team BTMC.
So we're just waiting on their match.
We're waiting on the final teams before we can watch the next game.
Next game is like...
Waste of Horse?
Dude, I'm not trying to pronounce that.
You guys try it.
How is there an H and an R next to each other?
How does that even sound?
Waste of Horse.
Like Hoff from Star Wars with an R.
Oh, like Hoff from Star Wars.
Like Hoff from Star Wars Harf.
Harf.
How about we just call it Waste?
That's a better idea, right?
The Waste.
So we got Team Hannah winning.
Well, we saw that one.
We had Team S Major win round 1 and Team Small Ant win...
Oh, Small Ant!
I didn't watch him too!
I was going to say, you guys might know Small Ant.
Small Ant's the team with...
Small Ant's the team with Feinberg.
You guys got there.
Yeah, I do!
Actually, all the time.
Well, we know which team Mint's going to cheer for.
Hey, it's the one with Feinberg on as well.
So that's the one you're cheering for too.
Oh, it's the Feinberg team!
Yeah!
Well, next round we have Team Snifferish vs.
Team Hannah.
Team Sparkles vs.
Team S Major.
Team Small Ant vs.
Team BTMC.
And Team Five Up vs.
Team Shubble.
Can we request which team we want to watch?
Let's just watch Team Small Ant.
Yeah, can we please?
Yeah, can we watch Small Ant?
Look, I think they're going to make it to the final.
So I think we will definitely see him at least once.
We think that's...
Yeah, it's going to be such a good game.
When I spectate someone though, they end up losing.
So I don't know.
Then we definitely should spectate Small Ant.
You're a jinx?
Yeah, I'm a bit of a jinx.
Alright, let's do it.
I'm doing my job of doing the analysis thing.
Right?
So all of the other teams that played each other, the team that got more kills usually took out the dragon and won the game.
But in the game that we watched, the red team got more kills but then lost to the blue team.
So it was like, I don't know, maybe it was like a strategy difference that maybe Team Red were just trying to kill too much and then wasn't focusing on the towers.
The blue team kind of held on to their ults for a long time.
True, yeah, you're right.
So maybe they more strategically used them to their advantage.
I think Team Red just might have got more kills, but they just don't look for flankers.
Because literally, they got that one guy sneaked in three or four different times.
And you know, you would think that after the second time, they learned from it, but then he just kept doing it.
Dude, they gotta have one guy on defense.
You need one person to stay back.
No, just maybe two.
Maybe two, right?
I think they had one guy on defense and then he dies to the other guy.
Right, they lose the 1v1.
Yeah, they lost the 1v1 and they're like, whoops, okay, that's my bad.
It just kept happening several times.
I think that's the reason why they lost.
Match 4 has their winner.
The winner was Team 5up.
Alright, how many matches are there in total again?
There's four matches going on at a time and there's five rounds.
So guys, there's still three more.
Wait, does that include the finals?
So yeah, there's four more to go, right?
We gotta watch four more, I think.
Yeah, but does that include the finals or is it the rounds for qualifying?
We got three group stage matches and then two, like a semi-final and a final.
There's two more group stages and then semis and then finals.
Yeah, okay.
Just for the people in chat, I totally knew that.
You were testing me.
I just wanted to ask these questions for chat.
I'm pretty sure they were curious about it too.
I just think Fulham is more articulate with how he can say the answers.
It's like a test.
We're testing him.
I'm here to be chat's representative.
I'm role-playing as chat, you know.
I'm asking the questions that they want to ask.
Oh yeah.
Chat, do you have any questions?
Yeah, if you have any questions, I'll ask them for you guys.
They're asking, why is Mint blue?
I told you, she's Winter Breeze Mint.
I'm Arctic Mint.
Oh yeah, it's like arctic foxes, where during the winter they change color.
Yeah, so they change color to white, but instead you change to blue.
I'm just a little...
Yeah, I'm a little shrunk today.
Yeah.
We're just waiting, guys.
We're just waiting for the next game right now.
And after that...
After that, we're gonna be gaming again.
I wonder what the next place is like.
We're gonna watch Small Ant.
Who's Small Ant playing against?
BTMC, right?
Yes, BTMC.
Alright.
Oh, there they are.
That's your favorite!
That's my Oshie!
That's your Minecraft Oshie!
That's my Minecraft Oshie!
Why couldn't that be me?
You should've been me!
Alright.
Dude, I have too much insight about most of the people on this team.
I am, like, very good friends with four-fifths of these people.
Moony is the only person I don't know.
I think Moony's a VTuber as well.
I'm not in the scene hugely.
I have played Minecraft once with Moony, though, and she was very cool.
So, we have Feinberg, who's like the guy, right?
The one guy that's really quick and really fast and cool.
Right?
But, if I tell you that Silver, the guy with the dog as the profile picture, when I tell you he's better than Feinberg is...
Is that a hot take?
Maybe I'm getting cancelled on Twitter right now.
Drama!
I'm gonna get called out, like, Oh, I prefer this friend to this friend.
I think Silver's a bit of a hidden gem.
You know what I mean?
I think Silver's a little bit of a... He's underground right now.
Oh, he's an up-and-comer.
Exactly.
Oh, look at this map.
So, he's just starting to get more and more records, right?
Oh, dude, yeah.
He's quicker than Feinberg is, bro.
I'm telling you that is a factor right now.
The opinions stated here do not reflect all of the co-captains in Doki Blade.
Minecraft fans, chill.
We don't know much about the community.
Just blame me.
It's okay.
You can keep blaming me.
So, it looks like there's some spawns down inside the crevice.
This is so cool.
It's like a two-tiered map.
You've got the top level which has the three lanes.
I mean, it's more open.
You're gonna struggle to...
You're gonna struggle to get one manned like the other team did.
There's no secret path through a building or whatever like before.
Jump!
Do they take damage if they fall?
No!
Oh my god, they're fine.
See, there is a bottom pathway.
They can get one guy.
There's literally one guy at the bottom right now.
There is.
There's one red team that's just like running from the bottom.
Oh, that must be the pot of gold.
No, it's gum-gum.
Why is it called gum-gum?
What does that mean?
Oh my god, it's gum-gum!
It's gum-gum, obviously!
Oh, my fault, my fault.
Sorry, sorry.
I should know.
It's gum-gum?
Sorry, sorry.
I completely forgot.
Like, duh, of course.
It's gum-gum.
First name, gum.
Second name, gum.
We were told by staff that it's gum-gum pistol but I don't think that explains anything.
Is it really?
That's One Piece, isn't that?
Oh, I'm making One Piece.
Yeah, I was gonna say man, oh my god, how are you an otaku and you don't know anything about One Piece?
I know the One Piece.
I can't believe it.
You're more of an anime fan than me and you didn't know about gum-gum pistol?
No?
Well, um...
Take my card.
Here you go.
Here's my otaku card.
It's yours now.
You can have it.
I don't care.
Whatever.
She doesn't care about you guys yet.
Wow.
How is that even real?
She hates you.
She doesn't care about the otakus.
One Piece is just not moe enough for me.
She doesn't care about anime anymore.
I used to be an otaku.
The blue myth is so mean.
The more blue she becomes, the more normie she is.
That's a scary thought.
Aw, the little axolotls are so cute.
Oh my god, wait, they gotta kill it for creep!
That's a creep!
How many people have fallen into the...
The hole?
Yeah.
I don't know how they get back up.
Where's the path back to the top?
There's a staircase on each side.
Oh, okay.
So there is a way to get out from the bottom.
Okay, I just said Silver runs that you are better, so you better not die here.
Oh, and he died.
Aww.
I'm telling ya.
I think I'm a hater, man.
I think I'm just a big hater.
Wait, which team is...
Is he also on Small Ant's team?
Yeah, he's on the Small Ant Feinberg team.
Well, let's see who's gonna do more...
make more contributions.
Feinberg or Silver?
True.
We're gonna find out who's the MVP.
Who's gonna be the MVP here?
There's so many legs.
The hoglins have cool little mohawks.
Rainbow mohawks.
That's so cool.
How do you see that?
Yeah, dude, next time you'll notice it now.
Look, the pig in the background.
Oh my god, he does.
He has a little rainbow mohawk.
That's cute.
Oh, wow.
Are they going for Gum Gum?
No, Gum Gum!
Oh, wait.
No, they're avoiding Gum Gum.
They don't need Gum Gum.
I thought they were gonna go solo the...
Oh, Blue Tower under attack.
Red are pushing.
Red are pushing and killing Blue's tower.
Yeah, where the heck is Blue Tower?
Yeah, I kinda can't tell which tower is which.
Yeah, I don't know which color is which.
There's Feinberg.
Gotta kill and he's just farming this spawner over here.
Getting as much coins as he can.
Getting as much upgrades.
I'm sure these guys have already analyzed which upgrade's best.
It's actually best to upgrade this to level 2 but don't upgrade it to level 3.
Before the tournament?
Well, they've got the documents and if I know anything about the Red team here these guys probably had a meeting like an hour ago going like, okay, this is the strategy.
We gotta do this.
This game is already out, right?
So they could've practiced beforehand, right?
True.
I don't know how they practice though.
I don't think these servers are public.
I don't think you can just play.
You can't just play it?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe, but I don't think so.
I think these guys have played in this event before, but I'm not sure if it's...
I don't know if you can just play anytime.
These servers, it's only for tournaments only.
I think so.
I don't want to get this wrong.
I'm the pro and I don't know for certain.
You're here to be our Minecraft analysis.
Is our Minecraft analysis guy gonna lie to us?
Am I actually trolling?
Oh my god.
Red tower under attack.
Thank you.
Thank you, voice line.
Red tower under attack.
Oh my god.
Thank god they told us.
I would've never known.
I actually wouldn't because we're just watching people fight.
Wait, red tower's taking so much damage.
Oh my god.
Looks like team blue are actually putting in the work here, but maybe it's just because team red trusts each other.
They go, yep, you're gonna go back to base.
You're gonna defend.
And look, they're not taking damage anymore.
And not anymore either.
Maybe they're relying on the timer.
Remember when the timer went lower and then all the towers got hit?
There's no timer anymore.
It starts at 10 minutes.
Oh, okay, okay.
I wonder if they're waiting for that because I feel like it's not that worth it if all the towers are just gonna take damage.
Gum gum got hit!
Gum gum!
No!
Nobody's paying attention to gum gum.
It's kind of sad.
Maybe he just...
Oh, there he is!
Yeah, slap him!
Slap gum gum!
That's right.
He's been a naughty gum gum.
2v1.
I feel like Climbug's not winning that one.
Maybe blue can take out the entirety of gum gum here.
They might be able to do it.
Hold on, someone's going for defending.
Oh, he ulted.
That has to be an ult.
Oh, here's the backup.
Cavalry's arrived.
Oh, he almost died for that too.
Wait, the red team has so many people dead already.
They had like 2 people dead earlier.
Oh, 2v3 now.
I feel like the plan is just let the other team get gum gum low and then come in for the steal.
Dude, I think these guys just won a 2v3.
I think the blue team just completely walked into their trap and like gave them 1v1s for no reason.
How did he die?
What?
Does gum gum deal back?
Gum gum hits back, bro.
Is it like knocking back or something?
Yeah, I was like, how did he die?
How did he die?
Let's go, gum gum.
Defend yourself, gum gum.
Oh, we have the red team rushing.
They're pushing.
Oh, never mind, blue team too.
Look out below!
Oh, look out below!
Dang!
0-3, It looks like red got it.
Red team got it.
They used two ults for it.
You see that?
They have like 3% ult now.
Oh yeah.
That's gotta be like an iron golem with a cool skin or something, right?
I think that's the case.
I think it's just gonna be like a teammate that can run in.
But you're right, I think the ult was used there.
Is it good to use it on the middle boss?
Maybe.
I don't know.
They also got kills from it too.
That's what I'm thinking.
I feel like it's good just because the blue team was just there for it.
Oh, see look, the timer started for the the half HP.
It starts at like 9 or 8 minutes.
Not 10.
The only issue is that now blue team has a lot of ults for this fight.
Oh, they still died.
I feel like there was more damage on the towers at this point last time, last match that we had.
Really?
I feel...
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe the analysis guys...
They got like the withers already, didn't they?
At least one of the withers.
That's what I thought.
I thought they had a wither down by now.
So maybe these guys are playing more defensive than the other team that we watched.
Or maybe this map is a bit too...
This map is a little bizarre.
It looks huge, like there's people at the bottom now versus the top.
It feels like there's so many places to defend versus the others.
Right.
The other one.
Oh my god, how am I gonna communicate with all that?
Red's attacking blue.
Oh, but look, they've teleported back.
He leaves.
Oh, unless...
2v1.
Oh, he won the 2v1.
Wait, did he?
No.
He teleported back.
Oh, he teleported back, yeah.
One of them died from it.
From that fight.
Their rabbit boy died.
That's a good trade still.
Look, they're jumping down, trying to avoid the fight, but still getting chased.
Yeah, there's no fall damage.
There's no fall damage for it.
Oh, there's his teammates right there though.
Oh, the creeps saved them.
What a hero.
He's going in.
Oh, nevermind.
No, he's going in.
Curry you.
3v1.
Oh my god, soothing minecraft music in the 3v1.
Oh my god, there's a blue sheep.
Red is so focused on this 2v1 that they're not focused on their towers.
They're getting damaged.
Oh my god, they're hiding down there.
Whose tower is getting hit right now?
I don't think anyone's tower is getting hit.
I think they're okay.
There's a big fight.
Blue is pretty good about defending their tower.
Yeah, yeah.
DTMC is going crazy.
And look, they're dealing some damage on the towers.
That wither's nearly dead.
That wither is dead.
Red wither gone.
One red wither is gone.
One red wither gone.
I think you might be a jinx, man.
I told you!
That's crazy because SmallHat's team is so stacked, not gonna lie.
Their team is really, really stacked.
I wonder if it's the map or what.
Maybe they're just focusing their priorities in the wrong places.
I think there's like four blue guys running down this mid lane right now.
Look, 4v1.
There we go, look.
Blue are launching a big attack here.
And they've got ults.
Look at their ults as well.
Okay, there's three.
There's the ult coming out.
The army is here.
I'm on fire today, baby.
Oh, man.
Wow, they got a crystal down.
They got a crystal.
Oh, it's not all the way down.
It's not all the way down.
But they used all their ults for that, though.
They used all their ults for that.
Oh, they're heading back.
They're heading over.
Oh my god, here's the counterattack.
They're pushing.
Oh my god.
They need to, though.
They really need to.
This is the perfect time, especially if, you know, they killed a lot of the enemies.
Minecraft analysis guy.
Is it like...
Is the blue team less stacked than the red team?
If I had to say, yeah, definitely.
I know that...
I'm not trying to be nasty, right?
I like the blue team as well.
Blue team definitely feel like they have one big carry.
And that's going to be FireBreathMan, which is the bunny boy.
A bunny boy.
Rabbit boy.
Yeah, rabbit boy is probably the best player on the blue team right now, FireBreathMan.
But I think that there's probably like two or three really good red teamers.
So, I don't know, but does red team have a bunny boy?
I think they... do they?
I don't know.
Yeah, they do.
Oh, there we go.
I was like, what?
There he is.
But I'm going to be honest, it looks like blue team are doing better.
They've got a crystal down.
They've got a tower down.
Yeah.
No, blue team is 100% doing better.
They... I feel like red team has not been focusing on attacking the base at all.
Maybe there's some secret.
Maybe red's just gearing up.
Maybe they've got all of the attack that they need right now.
I mean, red do have three ults.
We'll see in like four minutes.
Look down below.
Oh, red are finally attacking.
Here we go.
Oh, they're getting two withers maybe.
Oh.
Okay, one down.
Nice.
One down.
They might grab another crystal.
Oh, the wither's pretty close.
Oh my god.
Trust the plan.
They wanted us to think that...
Oh my god.
Look at this attack.
Wait, they're going crazy.
Finebug's trying to take out two here.
Takes out one.
Oh my god.
Wait, they might get another wither.
They might get another crystal here.
Oh wait, that's so close.
Oh my god, we should have trusted the plan.
We should have trusted the plan.
There's a second crystal.
I'm assuming... Oh my god, just one more.
Oh my god, just one more wither.
They're all dead though.
What a crazy counterattack by red, man.
That was so cool.
Yeah, but they still have like two...
They're going to a counterattack and they only have two people alive.
Oh no, they're going to get hurt.
I think the respawns are going to be okay, I think.
And Rad still has her ultimate ability as well.
Well, Meow and Smallant still have another...
Oh, just kidding.
No, Rad says they're all...
Yeah, yeah.
No, I just meant the respawn.
Oh, respawn, yeah.
They're all back.
So it looks like both teams kind of have one ult left now.
Oh my god, he's hulking up!
The tower's gone!
Oh my god!
Killed it with his last swing.
Feinberg dies there, but...
Wait, three people are already...
Wait, three people are already dead.
Blue team is still up.
But I don't... Oh, Smallant's hiding!
Oh no, he gets found.
Oh no!
But look, he's leading the entire team downstairs.
Maybe this is a good counterattack chance.
I mean, their respawns are back now.
All the respawns are back, but... Just dragging this one player away is so smart.
Wait, there's only one crystal left for blue team.
He's coming.
He's on the hunt.
Oh, he's distracted by the hunt.
He got distracted!
He saw the distraction and he was like, oh my...
Mob break, you know?
Just a little ADHD there.
I think this 1v1 is huge.
He's cool as a cucumber.
His heart rate is only 85.
He knows what he's doing.
He just went for a little detour mission there with the freaking Hoglin.
Well, the red team is pushing.
They're like...
I don't think they're going to take the 1v3 here.
No, red team dies.
But I think that might be Feinberg in the back there.
Feinberg is there, killing the crows.
Oh, the crystal!
Oh, the crystal's down!
Feinberg dies, but it's down to the dragon.
They had the dragon.
I mean, you've got to be favoriting the red team here.
I think red team are probably the...
The favorites right now, yeah.
I think that's...
The content team, that's brilliant.
Yeah, yeah.
But I mean, blue are pushing.
Look, they're trying to flank outside of this mid lane, but...
Oh, they got a kill, though.
They got one guy over there.
He was like...
Wait, oh my god!
That's so much damage!
Red tower's almost dead.
Almost done, yeah.
Yeah, but they still need to get the two other crystals.
But they're half down.
It's because of the timer thing.
Remember when they...
They did the timer thing where they...
Oh, GumGum's back!
I'm coming, I'm back!
I'm coming for you!
GumGum!
Who just went in there?
Oh, red team are dealing damage to the dragon, finally.
Oh, they're ulting.
They have...
Oh, they're dying, though.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, this is gonna be it, surely.
Blue used an ult and got them dead.
They're so close.
They have to do a counterattack right now.
But there's only two of them.
Maybe just one guy sneaking in would be...
Yeah, one guy is enough.
We saw that last game, right?
Just need to get five or six hits on that dragon and it's gonna be over.
GumGum's just sitting there.
No, don't kill GumGum!
Good.
I want GumGum to just slap them and then they fall.
Just one little shot.
Red almost have their ults back as well.
Look, 83, 81.
Yeah, they just need one good ult.
If they count... If they, like, defend... If red can defend this, they can just counterattack and win.
Yeah, for real.
And it's a 4v3 in red's favor.
I think, like, red is... I can't tell, but does red have more money?
I think they do because they got GumGum in the middle, right?
They got the first GumGum, that is.
Yeah.
Oh, they won the fight.
They killed almost everybody in blue.
But I think two of blue survived.
Yeah, two blue survived.
Oh, there's one more defender, though.
They're onto the crystal.
Okay, one blue down.
Oh, no.
Okay.
There's the second blue gone.
They need some sort of counterattack now, though.
Oh, he hid!
Smallman tried to hide, but not gonna get the death.
He tried to hide!
He tried to hide to get the...
That's smart.
That's such a smart, like, tactic.
When they're rushing to the other base.
Yeah.
Yeah, hiding over there.
Yeah, hiding over there just for the sneak attack.
GumGum!
No!
Are they gonna kill GumGum?
I'm surprised.
Why are they shooting GumGum?
They're wasting time.
You just need to do this much damage to the dragon.
Oh, maybe.
What if there's one guy on the outside?
That's what it looks like there is.
Maybe they're using him as a distraction.
Whoa, where did he fly to?
Did you see that?
His ult, his ult.
Watch out below!
Watch out, man!
It kinda worked, as well.
Look at this.
Firebug falls off, and now it's a 4v2.
All four of them!
This is huge, actually.
This is actually insane.
Blue could do this.
Blue can come back here.
It's a 4v0.
Firebug's alive, but what's he gonna do?
It's one defender against four.
Power down.
They're killing the crystal.
Firebug has his ult.
Can Firebug's ult actually work?
Oh my god, SmallAnt.
He's on his own.
Can SmallAnt win?
He's dealing damage!
SmallAnt one-mans it!
Wow!
Who was that?
SmallAnt snuck around, just like he did.
The one guy.
You muted yourself.
You were so excited.
What an absolutely beautiful kill.
That was so close.
That was actually so crazy.
That was really smart to let them take out the tower so they wouldn't notice that someone was killing the dragon.
They thought they were waiting for respawn, but he was just on the other side of the map.
They basically baited him.
They baited the entire team to get closer to the dragon so they could sneak in.
That's insane.
So he dropped down.
He dropped down purposely just to do the flank.
That was so smart.
Wow.
That was a close game.
That was a really close game.
See?
You're not a jinx!
I know!
The comeback!
You gave them the comeback.
I never doubted them for a second, but maybe one second.
Just one percent of that.
It was risky though.
Especially if all four of them were hitting the other dragon, they could've been getting more damage.
They could've out-timed.
I don't know what ult that is.
A giant cat in the middle running around.
It's like, I'm ulting out.
It's so big compared to everybody too.
I know!
That's funny.
I mean, the spam damage is kind of crazy.
I don't think I played Minecraft when that was...
I don't know actually.
I never did think of competitive.
I haven't either.
I used to spam damage and then my chat would yell at me.
Stop spamming!
You're not getting the optimal strong hits.
Yeah.
Now we can give an excuse.
It's because we were watching this MOBA tournament.
We thought it was the thing.
We were watching professionals.
If they did it, I would do it.
That's what we learned.
We actually do have all the teams for round 2.
For that, we have Team Hannah winning round 2 again.
That's their second win.
Who did they win against?
Team Snifferfish.
Team Sparkles won against Team S Major.
Team SmallAnt won against Team BTMC.
Sorry, no bias.
No caster bias, of course.
No, of course not.
Team FiveUp wins against Team Shubble.
Which that is Team Shubble and Team BTMC.
They both have two losses.
Next game would be the final group stage.
After that would be semis and then finals.
We'll see how it goes from there.
Has the matchup for the next group stage been up yet or no?
No, not...
Oh wait, yes it is.
Sorry, I'm a liar.
Round 3, we're in Sweet Peaks, baby!
Wow!
Sweet Peaks.
We have Team Snifferfish versus Team Sparkles.
Team Hannah versus Team S Major.
Team SmallAnt versus Team FiveUp and Team BTMC versus Team Shubble.
I don't know who to watch.
Has anyone watched Hannah, Sparkles and SmallAnt, your oshi?
Yeah.
I don't really know the other teams as well.
I don't either.
We'll wait for Fulham to come back.
Our professional Minecraft analysis guy.
I wonder if he has a degree.
In Minecraft?
In what?
In Minecraft, yeah.
Oh, they're saying SmallAnt versus FiveUp.
We don't get a choice.
We don't.
Oh, no.
The spectator.
The spectator curse.
I'm eating my popcorn.
Oh, yeah, your popcorn.
Wait, did you tell Chad that you brought popcorn to eat for the tournament?
No, I didn't.
Guys, I have popcorn.
Yeah, she has popcorn for this exciting tournament.
Wait, our British Captain Sparkles is back.
Oh, British Captain Sparkles.
Welcome back.
I think our Chad's gonna forget what his actual name is with the stuff we're saying.
We just keep calling him, like, Minecraft analysis guy and British Captain Sparkles.
I say Fulham.
Fulham.
He has a name.
He has a...
Big Ham.
Large Pig.
Oh, wow.
British commentator man.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, there's a shop.
I love that one time when, like, their dragons were getting attacked and then they just went for...
went to the shopkeeper.
It's like, when your dragons get attacked, it's not time to shop right now.
It's not shopping time.
I think we're at Sweet Peaks now.
That's the map that we're at.
Oh, it's like, it's actually sweet.
It's like candy.
Yeah, candy land.
Thank you guys for holding down the fort.
I kinda needed to go pee, I'm gonna be honest.
Oh, we were wondering, what degree do you have?
In Minecraft.
How did you know that I have a degree?
Yeah, what kind of degree do you have?
Yeah, what's your credential?
Your Minecraft credentials.
Oh, my Minecraft credentials.
To be a professional Minecrafter.
Your degree.
What school did you taught yourself?
In reality, in real life, I have an engineering degree.
But, in Minecraft, I think that's how you calculate stuff.
Yeah, that's like a redstone degree or something, maybe, like something like that, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to translate it to Minecraft.
What did you want it to be before Minecraft ruined your life?
Oh, no.
You can say that.
You are 100% allowed to say that.
I could have done anything, bro.
I have a whole ass degree and then I went, yeah, but Minecraft's really fun.
I could just do that all the time instead.
That's true.
It's way more fun than having to do numbers and stupid stuff like that, dude.
Oh, we're being told to explain some things for this match, I think.
So, actually, we mentioned before how this is not like the first time they've done this tournament and they have actually two new characters and they want us to talk about one of the characters is Harmony.
Harmony is being played by 5UPS and she is a scout and she's 29 years old.
She's probably single and probably likes...
What are her likes and dislikes?
What are her hobbies?
She probably likes long walks on the beach, you know?
I need the whole dating profile, please.
This is really important.
For chat, obviously.
Wait, she has a cat.
She fights with her cat.
Which way are we swiping?
Oh my god, is Rattle playing?
Oh my god, yeah, Rattle's playing as Harmony.
This makes sense.
Yeah, you can see the cat on the head, the green cat.
Oh my god, that's awesome.
It's so cute!
Is that the old thing?
Does the cat become huge?
Yes!
Oh my god, Rascal!
Rascal!
That is so cute.
So the cat hulks out then.
I see.
Yeah, so Harmony and Rascal are the newest character addition for...
and then I guess for this tournament, yeah.
Wait, who's the other character?
Um, I don't think SirBlock is new per se, at least I didn't say, but SmallAnt is playing as SirBlock.
That guy is a dapper man with a suit and tie and he's got a green aura.
Wait, SmallAnt's playing him, right?
Is that him?
Yeah, I see the green aura.
He's so dapper.
I'll pay...
I'll pay a Minecraft player $100 if they play Granny Hag.
Dude, we need Granny Hag.
Where is Granny Hag?
We need Slam Hag!
Literally, she must be not meta, right?
The devs might be watching right now.
You can tune up her...
Yeah, tune up her right now.
Right now.
Just don't tell anybody.
Only the real ones will know.
Just for one game, but for right now.
They're fighting little candy zombies.
This is so cute.
Oh wait, really?
Oh my god, they are.
I like how the mobs are themed towards the maps too.
Got Feinberg coming in.
Oh, wait, Reinho.
Oh, isn't she a VTuber?
Reinho is a VTuber.
Man, her name literally has VT at the end.
Oh, you're right!
I didn't see it.
It stands for virtual tub or something.
I wasn't looking at the sides.
I was looking at her name above and I didn't see it.
Her VT for a minute sounds very tubular.
Very tubular.
That's what the VT stands for.
If you see somebody's name at the end, that's VT.
They're very cool.
Feinberg coming in.
I like how they're alerted when someone is close to base because the withers just start going crazy.
There's not really ways to sneak in.
There's a lot of hiding spots though.
Oh my god, wait, Feinberg lost the 1v1.
I think that's Feinberg, right?
The Feinberg won the 1v1.
Oh my god, he's a little sneaky.
You're right, there are a lot of hiding spots.
Yeah, there's so many hiding spots here.
He has no idea.
Oh my god, he's gonna get ambushed.
Oh my god!
That's crazy.
What a beautiful little hiding spot.
No, he didn't.
But Silva's there to clean up the pieces.
Wait, no, he lived.
Yeah, wait, the red team won the fight.
Yeah, Silva came in from the side and was able to clean it up.
Nobody died during that.
On the other side.
This map is much bigger but also has a little canyon in the middle too.
Oh my god, it's a cake!
The devil's food cake!
That is so cool.
Wait, I just realized why we saw slime earlier, because their textures were breaking.
That's why we saw slime for pot of gold.
We accidentally saw behind the Wizard of Oz's curtain.
Sorry everybody, your immersion.
I was wondering why the slime was called pot of gold.
Small ant running away.
There he goes.
Run.
He's gonna get ya.
This map is crazy.
This is why bunny boy is so overpowered here, because if you're getting chased like this, you can just catch up.
There's no way they can outrun you.
I think bunny boy is really good for flanking too.
To get the main tower and stuff.
He seems like...
It looks like every team has a similar sort of comp as well.
A lot of them have one harmony and one surblock and then you've got the bunny guy and the two minotaurs, I think.
I feel like Feinberg's team has to be the meta team, because I've seen that comp the most.
Yeah, for real.
It's very similar between the two, it's just that small ant is using the surblock and then on the other team, Redoonz is using a different character that I don't know if we've seen.
That's not the granny, right?
That's not the granny.
No, granny is actually slimy.
Who's that character?
That might be Axel?
Is that Axel?
Oh no, just kidding, he's a minotaur.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I thought Axel was a minotaur.
Let's see, I'm looking through the characters.
Oh wait!
No, I don't know.
She has brown short hair.
Mmm?
I'm not sure, it could be the side.
We should ask our Minecraft analyst guy.
He should know.
I'm trying to find out.
He should know as the professional Minecraft analysis guy who didn't fake his credentials.
He has an actual degree in redstone.
I have a degree from Glock University.
So who is that character that they're playing?
I mean...
erm...
I think we should just make something up and then we'll agree.
I feel like, yeah.
Is that... okay, it might be Tulibot, which is a cyborg.
That's what I said, it might be the cyborg.
Wait, are you making stuff up or is that an actual...
No, this is a guy.
No, it says robotic glasses covering eyes.
But it says eyes.
Yeah, right?
There's only one eye covered though.
I feel like there's a couple characters we haven't seen, like the great mage, I don't think we've seen him.
Ooh, someone used an alt there.
I didn't hear what that was.
Pew pew, did you hear that?
He's like, pew pew.
That's Rattles, that's my goat.
Let's go, Rad.
It kind of makes sense as well, because her Vtuber model is a catgirl and she's using the class, which has the cat and the catgirl is like a...
Hulking out cat.
Well, that's so perfect then.
That's so funny.
Hulking out cat.
He's like, cootie smash.
We need a reskin of it for you Doki and it's Garfield instead.
Garfield.
Garfield smash.
My money's gone.
Lasagna where?
I don't know why he's becoming more like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Mondays at my rate.
Lasagna.
Sounds like Garfield hates Mondays.
The only kind of damage we have so far is the red team has a tiny bit of damage against autowither.
It seems like the first 10 minutes are pretty... It's just farming pretty much, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that's what MOBAs are.
It's just, for me...
Oh, Red are attacking right now though.
Oh, they're attacking.
Oh, there you go.
They're going in.
Thank god.
This is what I personally have initially with MOBAs.
It's just the first 10 minutes is just farming.
It feels like that for sure.
But when you get to the action part, it's really fun.
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god, he's cute.
Mondays!
Oh my god, look at him go!
Oh my god, he's so fast!
No!
Garfield!
Garfield.
Ripped to a legend.
What's so great, what's so funny about Harmony is each of the character profiles has, like, why they're playing the games.
And she plays for her cat.
She plays for... I feel like the cat just wants...
I think the cat is the one that wants to be in this game.
For real, right?
Yeah.
So, Rascal battles furiously to defend Harmony, always staying within a 16 block range of the player until his HP energy runs out.
If Harmony dies whilst Rascal is mid ult, he enters rage mode.
So, like, he goes rage mode when she's dead.
Yeah, but he has to be, like, in...
He has to be, like, kind of already mid ult.
Already mid ult.
I love that.
Red are attacking again.
They put a tower down.
We already got a tower down so fast.
They're being a little more aggressive this time.
Oh my god, I think red team might be better.
Scrungle.
Already 10 minutes in and they already got a tower?
That's crazy.
That's really good for them.
I like this tiny view we got going on.
What was that?
Oh yeah, the tiny POV there.
Is there any worth going into the crevice?
Or is it a death?
Do you die down there?
It doesn't seem...
I was thinking, is the crater the second map that we had?
No, it doesn't seem to be the case.
I think it looks like...
It's like Willy Wonka down there.
You die in the chocolate sauce.
This is the chocolate factory.
Yeah.
I mean, blue have done some damage on the red withers, but not very much.
I'm going to be honest, I feel like red are kind of overpowered here.
Feinberg takes out two.
Oh my god, yeah, I was going to say they just killed so many people.
Damn.
But to be fair, the blue team lost three there.
So they're like even pretty much.
You know what I want to see?
I want to see Willy Wonka do a battle royale with children.
Is that not just the regular plot of the movie?
But they don't...
They don't die.
Well, hey, you don't know where they go, right?
One of them turns into a blueberry.
Yeah, but she's still alive.
She has to live her life in the factory, like as a blueberry.
What kind of life is that?
It's basically death sentence.
Hey,
we've used our two slip-ups already.
Red are pushing and they have their ults.
There's four.
Oh, one person's already dead.
Finebug's just written this crystal out.
Crystal down.
Yep.
I'm surprised they've not used their ults yet.
Everyone's got their silver as it as well.
That's crazy!
But the red team did lose a tower.
Yeah, I think like...
Someone's attacking red as well.
Yeah, someone on blue team is attacking them right now.
Or they were, because nothing is...
Dude, silver's going crazy on these kills right now, but finally they got enough respawns.
Finebug got a crystal down.
He can't take the 1v3.
He cannot take that 1v3.
They're doing a counter attack, but they just need one person to sneak in.
That's it.
What is Axel's...
Finebug's...
He has three ults.
Red team has three ults.
Dude, I'm surprised they didn't use them.
I know that Smallant used his, because his is down below.
What's crazy, each character even has their own passive, so that's probably why the meta is like, you know, this kind of build.
The ults for...
Axel, the Minotaur guy.
Oh, it like locks people in.
Yeah, it stuns them, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
It makes them faster.
Finebug used his ult.
It makes them land attacks more quickly.
Oh, yeah, they died.
Oh my god, dude.
Rascal's goated up right now.
No, Rascal!
No!
Someone from the blue team just fell.
Oh my god, the dragons!
The crystals are down!
It's just the dragon!
He's chasing him!
Are we gonna see a flank from blue team, or are red team gonna take this down?
Oh...
Oh wait, they just need to use the Rascal ult, and then like just run to the dragon and get into rage mode.
And Rad's at 95% on the Rascal ult right now, so definitely could do, maybe, in a few seconds.
But she might die here, she's dead.
We gotta see her respawn first.
Oh, but here he goes!
And there it is!
Wow, that was fast.
That had to be the fastest team.
That was a super quick game, yeah.
15 minutes.
I think SmallAnt's team is like really overpowered compared to the other team.
That's crazy.
That might actually be our first win of the entire round, out of all the teams that are going against each other.
I think it was.
I think it was the fastest match out of the like four matches we have going on.
That was fast, yeah.
That was so fast.
That was fast.
They like took like three towers down within like ten minutes and everything.
The highlights, our little recap reel.
Watching him go...
Hulk mode.
I love that the cat turns into a huge...
a huge like a rage cat that just tries to defeat everything.
I love that.
I know.
He's like times three bigger than everybody else too.
Yeah.
He's just like, I'm angry.
Goodbye, SmallAnt.
Oh, and the win.
Yeah, baby.
Here it is.
Victory!
That was some intense games.
We do have another.
Team BTMC actually won against Team Shubble.
Shubble?
Where do you see that?
Oh, I see it.
Guys, I am professional.
Yeah.
Yeah, professional.
Wait, that means their game must be really fast too.
Dude, that was fast.
That was pretty fast.
Did they finish theirs before us?
No, no, we finished.
It was really close though, yeah.
Oh, so I heard that Fulham has something to say to us.
Yeah, I think I'm meant to say a big, huge thank you to H&R Block for making awesome things happen in gaming.
And you guys should make sure to go check out Luna Client and check out the free HRB Cosmetics.
Because with HRB Block, it is better with Block.
That's all I have to say.
Now, I'm so grateful that you guys were dancing and jumping around during that.
That was super, super helpful.
Yes, thank you for watching.
Hey, shout out to those guys, but we're done now.
It's okay.
Hey, we're back.
We're back and ready to talk about the MOBA.
We're back, guys.
We're back.
No skipper, skipper.
Yeah, we wouldn't be able to have the tournament without you guys.
Guys, go check them out.
New exclamation point Luna in either of our chats.
More details about our wonderful sponsor.
Yeah, you can go to the link and get the little cosmetic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, Min was telling me how she was setting up her bot for the first time for the stream and was not having a good time.
I started streaming and it immediately started banning everybody else.
Why was it banning?
What did you do?
Because it was just like people are spamming emotes.
It was like if you post more than three emotes, I'm gonna ban you.
It was like ten people at once.
It was crazy.
Nightbot is only here for the lunar skin.
Cosmetic.
Lunar cosmetic.
That's funny.
They're like, how dare you spam.
It's okay, guys.
You can...
Oh wait, no.
Oh wait.
You can do it on my...
You can't do it on my YouTube, but you can spam emotes on my Twitch channel.
Dude, bots can be like that.
Especially when you first set them up.
It's like, uh-oh.
Nope.
Something's going wrong here.
Someone's being rude and too many exclamation marks.
Come on.
Relax, man.
It's okay.
It's so sensitive.
Hey, it's okay to be sensitive sometimes.
It has to for those who don't have mods.
Right, yeah.
Someone says self-moderate and stuff.
It has to be super sensitive.
One wrong move makes it goodbye channel.
I know.
Well, we are in the final two rounds.
It's semi-finals next, guys.
Oh my gosh.
We're already at the semis.
I know.
We're zooming.
Who's in the semi-finals?
What are the match-ups for the semi-finals?
I mean, we're still waiting on some of the outcomes of the games, but I think that given the fact that we saw Team Smallant win two games, that's big.
And I literally just heard my friend scream from next door.
So I think they might have just won.
Oh, so Sparkle's won against Sniffer, then.
I believe so.
Yes, I'm seeing them entering it now.
I can see it in the game's log.
Actually, well, yeah.
So we have...
I think Hana has won.
Well, we just need to know if Hana wins her game.
Yeah, because that would be three wins for Hana.
Yeah, because if Hana would have won all her games, I believe Smallant won all his games too, right?
Yes.
I mean, this is not gospel.
This is not confirmed, but I'm going to assume that it sounds like it might be Team Sparkle versus Smallant.
And then, I think it might be Team Hana versus FiveUp?
I'm not sure on that second matchup.
I'm not 100% sure.
Sparkle, Hana, and Smallant are definitely in the semis.
Wait, how many...
Do all groups qualify for semifinals?
Yeah, so I think this is where it splits off into two different brackets where...
Is it a loser bracket or a winner's bracket?
Yeah, exactly.
I think they call it a consolation bracket because I think loser sounds rude, right?
No one's a loser.
Everyone's a winner.
No, you're fine.
I call it a loser bracket.
We all have to accept it as I grow up.
Hey,
we're sensitive Minecraft players.
We can't be called losers, okay?
Hey, be nice.
We're runners-up.
We're consolation brackets.
You know what I mean?
Don't say the L word here, Tokyo.
I'm sorry.
I've been a loser before in tournaments.
I just thought it'd be the same.
Hey, it's okay to be a loser.
Wait, so are the semis going at the same... sorry, the consolation bracket and the winner's bracket?
Yeah, they both happen at the same time, right?
They're going at the same time, okay.
I think we're going to be focusing on whoever is in the winner's bracket though, you know what I mean?
I feel like that's maybe more important.
But this pretty much determines whether these teams are going to be finishing in the top four or the bottom four.
Because that's now all done from the group stages, but from now on, it all depends on whether they're going to win these bracket matchups.
So, once we go through these semifinals, the last match will be... we'll watch the finals, but there's also going to be a third place match, I think, running at the same time.
I'm going to check what the behind the scenes are saying, but yeah, I think that seems to be usually what the run of play is.
And I think we're just waiting on that final game to see who's playing who in this finale.
Oh, I think we just got it in.
There it is.
Team Hannah gets their third win!
Yeah, so it is SmallAnt, Hannah, and Sparklez.
I think so.
And then I'm not sure who that fourth team is, but I think...
Because I know there's some tiebreakers and things like that.
Now, as much as I'm the quote-unquote pro, I don't know everything about it.
I need to do some research.
Someone's going to...
Someone will tell me in my ear in a little minute and say, hey, these are the matchups.
So, we'll find that out very soon.
Okay, soon, soon.
I think they're...
They're asking me to do something too, and I'm like, how do I do that?
Oh, she's...
Toki is buffering.
Everybody, please hold.
Guys, please hold.
I'm trying to figure out this thing that they're trying to tell me to do, and I'm like, but how?
I never...
I don't know when I did that.
That was my before 10s.
Okay.
Buffer, buffer.
Oh my god.
Guys, please hold.
I'm buffering right now because I'm trying to figure this out.
I think they're helping you.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I might be wrong.
I tried to give you a suggestion, but it might not even be correct, dude.
Okay, alright.
Is this our fourth map?
Is this Goldmire Gulch?
Goldmire...
Oh!
Goldmire Gulch.
It looks like the first city we were at.
Just sunset.
Does it?
Oh, it does, sort of.
Yeah.
I think we're just chilling.
I think 5UP's gonna find out whether they've made it to the top bracket or the bottom bracket.
Oh, maybe that's the lobby.
Maybe that's the lobby.
Hi, 5UP.
You go do your thing.
I believe in you.
They're exploring.
They're giving us a little tour of the city.
Yeah.
They're giving us a little tour while we figure this out.
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
Wow.
Alright.
You go carry the casting real quick while I figure out settings.
Me?
Okay.
Okay, Fulham, I'm gonna question you.
Oh god, am I gonna get interviewed live?
This is scary.
I haven't prepared my answers.
Help.
Um...
What's your favorite Minecraft mob?
That's a really good question.
Don't lie.
No, I have to think about it.
You know what I mean?
Okay, right.
I like...
Oh dude, they all kind of suck.
Like, I don't like any of them.
Woah!
Live on stream?
Dude, what is...
Like, I can't say skeletons.
Skeletons are so annoying.
Do you think that Enderman is sexy?
Oh, okay.
Hey, am I allowed to speak about this?
On stream?
Yeah.
Oh, definitely Wither Skeleton.
Definitely Wither Skeleton.
Yeah, dude.
They're crazy tall.
Hello?
Three blocks tall?
Skinny?
Damn, okay.
I didn't know you were built like that.
Then where is the Enderman fall into this case?
Oh, hey, Enderman's cool.
Yeah, but they can teleport.
And that freaks me out.
They can teleport and that freaks me out.
You know what I mean?
At least the Wither Skeletons, they've got a similar build.
But, you know, one of them can teleport and one of them can't.
You know what I mean?
And you can't look at Enderman in the eyes.
That's something that you learn on day one.
So you're afraid of commitment.
Oh, you're right.
Sorry, I just registered that.
I fixed it.
Okay, what is...
Okay, so what is your first thing you do when you are speed running on Minecraft?
Punch a tree.
Oh, that makes so much sense.
It's just like a real Minecraft playthrough.
It's like your Let's Play.
You gotta punch a tree.
It's pretty universal.
What's your type then?
Yeah, spin the question.
I think it's obvious.
Enderman.
Okay, but what makes the Enderman your type?
I kind of like that he teleports because I never know what's going to happen.
It's going to come up behind me.
Hey, yo!
Damn, Freaky!
What about you, Doki?
Come on.
Me?
I don't play Minecraft enough to...
Oh, come on.
Shut up.
I'm trying to dodge the question.
We're all airing our dirty laundry here.
Come on.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait.
What are the mobs again?
They're going to kick me out of Minecraft University because of this stream.
You better at least answer the question.
Because of this stream?
Just because they're like, Whoa, Wither Skeleton.
Yeah, right?
Then what's the right answer that would get you approved in Minecraft University?
Dude, you have to be like, Like, no one.
Oh, I love the Minecraft too much.
Like, no.
What a boring answer.
Doki,
I feel like for you, it would be an Iron Golem.
Why the Iron Golem?
It's the closest to a robot.
That's crazy.
Okay, look.
Look, I just think certain Transformers are made, designed to be pretty wild.
I'm trying to be PG.
Hey, I think Iron Golems are tall.
They deal a lot of damage if you're into that.
I don't know.
They can carry me.
And if you're nice to them, they give you flowers.
That's real.
That's in the game.
That's so romantic.
Why didn't you pick Iron Golems?
I didn't even think about that.
They give you a flower.
Oh my god, they can protect me.
Oh my god, you're so...
They protect you, they give you flowers.
This is a good answer.
I don't understand.
You chose Endermen, but they're like the dead beats of Minecraft.
No, they pick up.
They are literally picking up stuff.
You splash water on them and they're gone.
They're never coming back.
The moment you splash a little water, they're not coming back.
Oh, we got an ad.
I'm kind of hungry.
Oh, we're going to be watching Team Hannah vs.
Firepup.
Oh my god, this is the gold minus emmys.
Wow!
I was so locked in.
I think I got the people right.
I think I got the matchups right.
I'm the Minecraft pro.
Yeah, you're chilling.
Team Hannah vs.
Team Firepup.
That's what we'll be spectating.
And then the other team is Team SmallAnt vs.
Team Sparkles.
Oh, wow!
Wait, do they take damage from the fire and stuff?
Yeah, I wonder if the lava hurts them.
You probably don't want to jump into the lava.
But I bet there's something inside the mouths.
You see how there's a bit of popcorn?
You have to jump for the beef, I think.
I think there's going to be the mobs that spawn in the middle that might give you lots of coins.
You've got to travel over that lava and not get hit off.
I like how some of my chat was like, is this the UK?
Hey, be nice, okay?
We don't have hot weather over here.
It would be raining.
If it was raining, yeah, that's the UK.
Yeah, it'd be a lot more grey.
That's true.
What's that new biome that turns the whole sky grey?
That's the UK?
Wait, did you see the newest updates in Minecraft?
Maybe someone should have been going for the creaking, bro.
They hide their hearts somewhere.
Actually, that's kind of not good to date.
The creaking.
Oh my god, this looks so gloomy.
We were just at the sweet map and now we're in the underworld.
I know.
It was really cute.
It's because we committed sin by talking about which Minecraft mob it is.
They're like, remember what you said.
What the heck is an Omnigast?
Omnigast?
It's got four faces, dude.
It's got a face on all of the sides.
Oh, that's gross.
I don't like that one.
Wait, can you ride the strider into the middle?
I wish, that would be awesome if you could.
That'd be cute.
Oh my god, they already killed somebody.
We already have aggression.
We were like, I miss gum gum.
Dude, oh, I miss gum gum too.
We all miss gum gum.
Gum gum is better than this Omnigast.
Omnigast, yeah.
Little rascals just chilling over there.
Jump into the lava, do it.
For science.
It'll be so funny.
Do it while the caster is watching.
We gotta find someone that jumps into the lava.
I'm sure that'll happen.
I'm sure that someone's gonna fall in.
Place your bets.
That's curious.
That's curious and be like, I wonder if I'll survive, you know?
Yeah.
Hmm.
The farming.
This is what kind of seems to happen at the start of every game, right?
They're just killing the mobs.
They're not worrying about kills or towers.
Oh, it's a zombie horse.
I love how a lot of the mobs are striders wearing a hat.
It's so cute.
Oh, dude, he's got a top hat on, hello?
Yeah, he's got his little hat on.
I like how they all have these little custom costumes, too.
Oh my god, no.
Leave those poor sh- Wait, is that bunny boy?
Is that the bunny boy skin?
He looks like the Easter rabbit.
We actually have a bit of variation in between the two teams this time.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, I see it.
Hangy's got the fire guy.
Hannah's team has like, yeah, Hannah's team has fire guy and, oh, bunny boy.
They still have bunny boy.
It's like fire guy versus...
What's the fire guy's name?
Have we figured out what that guy is yet?
Dude, no.
We still haven't figured it out.
You could have given me an hour, I read through this document, I'm like, I have no idea.
Maybe the mods, maybe the admins know.
Admins, if you're watching, what is that?
What is...
Yeah.
We know you're watching.
Do one of you two want to try and tell me what Pangy's name is?
It's the Pyro Elemental.
You guys can say the name though.
Oh, I'll find it.
Hold on.
I've got it on my screen, but I'm going to let you read it.
Ignis Ullabagin Saint Germain Kedrick Von Constantine.
That's the one.
I would have said that too, but I was a bit, you know...
I had something in my throat.
Oh, okay.
Why is my table floating?
What did you just say?
The admin said that, but still won't tell us what the fork is.
Tell me what the guy is playing.
I'm just going to screenshot it and say, who is this?
Who is this?
They responded to Min saying a name of, but we still don't know who this guy is.
We need to know the one with the scouter, the dragon ball scouter.
Oh, it is Chulibot!
I got it right!
It's fine.
I'm back as the Minecraft pro.
I'm the goat like that.
I got it right.
Get off your high horse now.
We need to knock you down.
Okay, sorry.
It wasn't you.
Are you sure you even went to Minecraft University?
Where's your degree?
Give me the lore on fire guy.
His hair is fire.
His hands are fire.
He's on fire.
Is that really the lore?
That's actually the character synopsis.
What?
Really?
There's no age or anything.
He's just on fire.
He's 28 years old.
He's old.
He's playing for the thrill of the game.
They've got a brother.
In the game, the lore says that they've got a brother.
Who's the brother?
Okay, it makes sense.
Actually, their brother is Froska Olwench St. Ward Bonstrap von Constantine, which kind of makes sense.
So there's a fire guy and an ice guy.
Oh my god.
It's just like that one song, that one movie where there was a fire guy and the ice guy in that Christmas movie.
Yeah, the Rudolph one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like Snowmizer and Firemizer.
They could've literally...
Oh my gosh, now I'm kind of sad that Team 2 didn't give us the brotherly showdown.
Did you see the picture they sent?
Alright, they're going for the ghast.
Oh, they almost got the ghast.
Who's the blue team again?
Team 5 up.
No one's damaged any crystals or any towers yet, but blue are probably getting the ghast.
It's still early.
Yeah, I assume it's also a lot harder too.
Oh, he's trying to steal.
Did he get the steal?
Did he get it?
I have no idea.
Loki, I hope he did.
I saw a plus 25 over him, but I'm not sure if that was...
I don't know.
I don't know if he stole it.
I can't tell.
It's very hard to tell from here if they stole it or not.
I like how he just ran up there and just slapped it and nobody cared.
They just let him slap the ghast.
I was like, okay.
Could have been a good time to sneak over to the blue team.
They got one guy again.
It's the same one guy from game one.
It's a one guy strat.
It's your buddy or your friend.
Your other friend.
You have too many friends.
I've got a few of them.
Don't worry.
I've got a couple more.
I'm going to say three people right now that are in this game that I don't like anymore.
Number one is...
I'm joking.
I can't do it.
I'll say it.
I don't like Doki Bird.
I hate you too.
It was all fake.
We manufactured it for stream because we know people love that shit.
I'm typing a twit longer right now.
Oh my god.
New drama.
You witnessed it all.
We're going to manufacture drama right now.
For the thrill.
For the excitement.
Just like that fire guy.
Mods, cut the camera.
We're going home.
We need a dramatic walk off set.
In fact, I'll do that.
I can't work with her.
And I just leave.
I can't keep casting if she's going to be in this call.
This is true.
This is the entertainment, everybody.
Oh my god, wait.
He's wearing a cowboy hat.
It's so cute.
Why is he yee-hawing in hell?
That's basically the place to yee-haw.
The little scarabs are cute too.
It looked like, just at a glance, it looked like blue team all had an ult.
Maybe they've been saving it up to try and do one big push.
I think all five of them have an ult.
We can't see it now.
Here we go.
All five of blue team have their ults ready.
Are they pushing?
To be fair, three of the red team do as well.
Yeah, blue team are pushing right now.
Red tower under attack.
They're all ulting.
One of them died already.
Need to get Pangi down.
There we go.
Pangi's dead.
Oh, but it's a 3v4.
They had enough time to respawn.
It's not going to do that much.
Yeah, because it's their first death.
Yeah, I was going to say, if this were late game, it would be huge.
It's not great.
I mean, yeah, it was an okay push, but they've all used their ults now, and they didn't do that much.
Red have three ults themselves and could do a really cool counterattack right now.
They seem to be heading over.
Oh!
Little flank there, but there's that one red guy that's kind of still protecting.
I don't know.
I don't know how many different paths there are into the dragon.
There has to be three lanes, right?
I think so.
In the jungle.
Technically.
I mean, that's usually how MOBAs go.
They usually have three lanes, and then there's the jungle where they can flank and stuff.
I mean, red team... Oh my god, one tower is almost gone, too, for red team.
Yeah, they were still able to do...
you know...
a chip of damage.
I can't tell.
Honestly, I feel like with the games going on right now, blue team is having an advantage over red team.
We saw small ants team destroy blue team.
So like...
True.
I feel like small ants team has to... Oh my god, see?
He's just hiding there.
Where is his healing?
Oh, and he popped out.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
Oh, that must be...
No, that's not his ult.
Oh, he's dead.
He's like, I can solo him.
And then he dies instantly.
Oh, that's a tower down.
That was a tower down, yeah.
Where did he get that tower?
I was like, for a non-league player, Doki knows a lot.
I played Deadlock, guys!
I played it!
She's a secret...
She's a league player in denial.
Truly.
I played Deadlock!
It's practically league.
Practically league is saying league in the same sentence.
No, it's not.
It is, actually.
It technically...
No, it's not.
League is like more miserable.
I don't know anything about MOBAs.
I'm here for the fun.
She's here for the thrill of it.
I'm here for the thrill of it.
Call me!
I'm here for the cat, bro.
I'm gonna be honest.
I'm only playing for my cat.
I'm here for GumGum.
I miss GumGum.
Bring GumGum back.
GumGum, final boss.
GumGum.
Just put...
Just change all the textures for GumGum at this point.
Instead of a wither skeleton that's guarded by a GumGum.
GumGum that shoots out little fireballs.
Is that tower down?
I think he's doing a lot of damage, to be fair.
Yeah.
Ow.
Couldn't one-man it, though.
Even though you got pretty close.
The health is low.
Yeah.
I mean, they're doing a one-guy strat again where everybody else acts as a distraction.
But I don't know if for this team if it works.
I love how the bun rabbit boy's costume is just a guy with rabbit ears.
It's like he's cosplaying right now.
It's okay to be a rabbit ear guy.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Nice shots.
Look at those dodges.
And then he died.
Oh, one...
Here we go.
The one-guy strat.
Or in this situation, one gal.
Hannah's right here.
Killing that mid tower.
Decides to dodge that tower and go for the one that has lower health to try and get it killed.
That's smart.
I don't know if it's smart against this team to do that because I feel like the other team is more like working together to grab the towers.
I mean, I think we'll find out.
But bear in mind, last match we watched was pretty much done at this point.
We got it done in 15 minutes, right?
We've only got one tower down.
And last time they had all the towers, all the crystals, and the dragon.
I think this match is definitely a lot slower.
They're a little more evenly matched.
I'd say.
I feel like...
Oh, wait.
Smine already won their game.
No way.
I'm on fire today, baby.
I'm not sure my chat's lying to me, but someone was like...
Someone wrote SmallAnt won.
No, I see it too.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't see it.
Just kidding.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my god.
That's crazy.
That's so fast.
I think, judging by...
Whoever wins this matchup, I think they're...
Because we saw Hanna won against CaptainSparklez.
And then SmallAnt demolished a five-ups team.
I think we can tell who's gonna win just from that.
Unless whoever's facing SmallAnt's gonna have the most miracle run ever.
It could be like a map goes against someone's play.
Or like underdog.
The underdog.
We don't wanna jinx anybody.
Maybe someone on SmallAnt's team crashes.
We just had another team come in.
Sniperish lost to Btmc.
Oh!
You see that little buffoo?
That's one of those lower bracket team matchups right there.
And that still matters because obviously the prizes are gonna change between 8th and 1st.
So even if you're in that lower bracket, you're still gonna try and get to that top 5.
If you can get 5th, that's still a big... Hey!
Everyone's gonna go home happy, I think.
Yeah, exactly.
BlueCrystal under attack.
Oh my gosh, she's taking him in an adventure right now.
It's going down!
Oh my gosh!
Is it getting solo'd?
Oh my god.
And there it is!
Oh, it's down!
And then the next tower!
1 HP on that tower.
I think they just died at the 1 HP.
Oh, that was close.
That's...
I mean, there's 9 seconds left.
After that, the whole tower takes damage, I believe.
Right?
Oh yeah, they're about to...
Wait, what?
What the hell?
Oh my god.
That counter is a little...
mysterious for us.
Yeah, I'm still a little mysterious.
I still don't understand.
And another tower down on the red team!
Yeah!
And they're going after the crystal.
Oh my gosh.
I guess that is... that has to be the mid-boss then.
Remember that one time when all the towers got hit?
I wonder what that was.
Yeah, the mid-boss is back.
I guess that was a mid-boss time.
I wonder what that was.
Remember when, like, when the timer was going down and all the towers got hit at once?
Oh, there it is!
Nevermind, it happened.
There it is!
There was a little delay, but there it is.
Oh my gosh, that really...
It really makes it look like everybody is kind of...
There it is.
I guess because they killed the boss the moment, the right time when the towers lost HP too.
So it was just timing-wise.
Oh my god.
Solo.
Let's go.
I can solo her.
That's the last tower!
That's the last wither down for Team 2!
Oh my god, the ult to the crystal is so smart.
I'm gonna deal damage to it.
Yeah, I think it really looks like Red are gonna take this down here.
Yay, we got the dragon!
They ulted to kill that last player, but I mean, it's all down to the dragon.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
There's still three crystals and a whole tower.
That's pretty rough for the whole team.
The crystals are almost down though, so it's not gonna be that rough.
They just need to make sure they grab...
Two people need to respawn, so the moment they kill one of them... Oh, Pengi has like... Oh, nevermind.
Pengi's back.
I was gonna say, Pengi has a long respawn, but he's back now.
Yeah, I think... Maybe there's an item that you can purchase too.
Cause I feel like... Respawn faster?
Yeah, you saw I said 58 seconds, and then they're back?
Yeah, it's happened to me before, so I'm wondering if maybe there's an item or something that allows them to respawn more like, faster to come in.
I think it may... Maybe it's just like the... Yeah, the timer looks like it counts down to zero and then keeps going a little bit further.
That's why.
Yeah, cause I was like wondering why it went zero and then like 59 58, and I was like, whoa that's long.
Is that an ult there?
Is that our fire there?
They almost...
They gotta sneak it in.
I mean, all of them are guarding it really well now.
The defense is really good.
But they need to offense too, like they can't just...
They're like, I'm gonna guard this dragon for 19 minutes.
Oh, oh!
Oh, they're on the crystal!
Oh, they got one of them.
They got one, yeah.
Yeah, blue dragon's under attack.
There it is, surely.
Oh, no way.
That was so close.
Red still have to push.
They've still got like 10% left of that dragon health.
I can't see blue coming back.
The thing is, they have three people that are down.
The blue team knows that three people are down so they're rushing it now.
Do you think they can rush in time?
Oh, Kaboodle!
Kaboodle got spotted!
They saw him though.
I don't know.
I think they're...
I don't think they're going after him though.
He's like, psych!
Oh my god.
If Cap goes back now, she might be able to get this next crystal.
Or get the last damage.
But no, blue are fully defending.
Blue are hard defending.
There was somebody at the red team.
Three are on the red side.
Three of them.
Two people died already on blue.
Coke our field!
Yeah, they defended it.
Hannah's defending really well.
Looks like...
Oh, here it is!
One man, again!
Same thing as last time.
Shatter goes through, gets that final few hits on the dragon, just flanks and wins.
It was worth it.
It was worth the risk.
So that means we have our finalists, right?
We have team Hannah vs team SmallAnt.
And in that third place matchup, it's going to be team Sparklez vs team FiveUp.
It's a pretty interesting matchup in both senses.
I assume we're going to be watching the grand finals here.
Hannah and SmallAnt.
Yeah.
I feel like it's going to be a really fast game.
Me too.
I just don't know who it's going to go to.
You don't have to be...
You don't have to pretend.
Okay, maybe that's true.
Fine, if I don't have to pretend, I know who it's going to.
I was going to say, Mr. Minecraft analysis, you don't have to pretend here.
Minna and I definitely know who it is.
We're giving everyone a fair shot.
It's all for the drama.
It all matters.
You know what I mean?
Anyone can win.
No one's a loser here.
It's just a consolation bracket.
Okay, but you're an analysis, right?
So you're here to talk about who you think is going to win as a Minecraft analysis.
I already told you...
Who do you think is going to win this tournament?
I already told you who I thought my underdog was.
And that man right there has silver runs.
I just cannot see anyone able to face up against him.
I think that he's, like I say, a little bit under the radar.
Maybe hidden gem.
Sleeper agent if you will.
A sleeper is...
Really, really strong player, but maybe under the radar a little bit.
Oh, 100%.
Hello?
Like, Feinberg is mid, but silver is the GOAT.
You know what I mean?
Clip it!
No!
I'm gonna get cancelled!
Clip it!
Fulham says Feinberg is mid.
But we don't believe that.
Mid and I do not share the same opinion, by the way.
We don't share the same opinion.
Do you guys think that team Feinberg and team Smolant are going to win though?
I think that's who the casters booth is supporting in this final matchup.
I think there is some biases.
Not from me, of course, but for a team.
There's never been biases anywhere.
I don't have any additional stakes that I've bet with anyone.
Not when we were talking about teams and your ears and eyes didn't perk up the moment you heard one of the teams that you get suspected.
I'm just saying that I...
You know...
It's just...
There's exciting people everywhere.
That's all I'm going to say.
Yeah, and which one were you most excited about mid?
Which one was it?
GumGum.
No, team GumGum.
I think GumGum's going to win.
He was there, not going to lie.
He was there!
The thing that's so interesting, like the game we just watched again, the team that won only got 30 kills and the team that lost got 60.
So like...
It's such a weird...
I think it's because of Hannah's strat.
They literally just send one person over and that's it.
And it works.
It does work though.
They lose their players during defense when they're defending the towers but then they only send people over to kill.
They just send one person over every time and it works for them.
And I think the rest of the team just focuses on farming creep too.
Which helps a lot.
Great analysis.
I believe we're watching the finals next, right?
I believe so and all of the teams are done.
So I guess they're just setting that up.
Who won what?
Can you read it out for me?
We have...
Team Hannah as our winner versus Team Fival.
Team Smallant as our winner versus Team Sparkles.
And then for the...
What are we calling them?
The small league?
Yeah, the little league.
I like that.
We have...
For the small league...
Oh god.
I feel like that's worse.
Little itty bitty league.
Those who are babies...
Team S Major as our winner versus Team Shubble.
And then...
Team TMC as our winner versus Team Snipperish.
Snipperish.
Which I was like, um...
It's average size.
I actually think it's quite a big league if I'm being honest with you.
I think it's above average league.
We're talking so much shit and we wouldn't be able to last like two seconds if we were...
If we were in this matchup we could absolutely destroy it.
Unless the admins keep us like creative mode or something.
But hey, we're the casters.
We're just here to let you know.
Casters doesn't mean they're the best players.
Look at other esports.
I shouldn't say that.
Oh, fine.
What, you calling me not the best player?
Okay, that's fine.
You guys can be rude and nasty to the pro.
It's fine.
No, you guys are right.
What do you mean?
Yeah, you're literally casting.
When are you gonna get into the match?
True.
Why are you just a caster?
It's because I'm washed, I think.
This guy...
No, we're not letting him in.
He's too good.
He wouldn't let the teams be balanced.
That's why you're a Minecraft professional analyst.
He's all speed, no skill.
You knew way too much that it just wouldn't be fair if you were part of the games.
Right, like...
Stop gassing him up.
Sorry, you can take him down a peg.
Oh, you're allowed to, don't worry.
We're doing good cop, bad cop.
It's your turn to be bad cop.
British!
No!
It's okay.
I will always have the British curse.
That's something I have to deal with for the rest of my life.
You can always leave.
No matter where I go, the British curse will follow.
That's...
No, you can pretend to be Australian.
Cute.
But then you'd be Australian.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what is that?
I'm excited for this map.
We are at Meow Meow Manor, everybody.
Meow Meow Manor.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
What a big boy.
I think that this, if I had to say...
Oh my god, more cats.
Oh!
Where does the...
Oh, I guess the dragon is down there.
They're just watching over the cats.
Oh!
I wonder if you can drop... I don't think you can drop down, right?
There's no way.
Oh, there's definitely little pods down here.
Look at this.
There's loads of hiding spots.
Apparently, this is a new map.
Oh!
So we're getting a first look at it.
Wow!
Wow, we're getting first exclusive look right here on this channel.
I think...
I think that the...
I think that the admins... the admins must love... must be cat people, right?
Because the new map, that's Cat Manor, or Meow Meow Manor, right?
And the new hero, or the new character, that's Harmony, right?
And Harmony has a cat.
I was like, no, Rascal is kind of the MVP.
Yeah, no, Rascal's the MVP for real.
Harmony is just a plus one.
Rascal's where we're at.
Rascal's the OG, yeah.
Oh my gosh, I love the way they did the drapes and everything.
That's so... it looks so good.
Are you writing it down for your next build?
Yeah, I'm getting inspo inspo right now.
This is beautiful.
This is a really good map.
Thank you to everyone who did the behind the scenes stuff.
I know there's a billion, grillion people that have worked on everything.
I assume so.
It looks so intricate and so detailed in general.
For real.
Oh my god, there's a secret tunnel?
Secret tunnel!
This is huge.
There's so many of these little hiding spots in different places.
And it's a 5v5, dude.
I feel like the one man strat works.
This is a big map.
It's a big map.
I think that's why the one man strat's been working so well.
It's such a big map and such a small team.
You can't defend it from all angles.
And Shatter we've seen killed that dragon twice now.
In two different matches.
In that one man strat.
I wonder if he can get away with this.
Cause this team SmallAnt's team is a lot stronger.
Yeah, it's definitely the biggest matchup that we're gonna see.
I think it's the most intense.
SmallAnt's team is very good at PvP too.
So it's like, I don't know if he's gonna get away with it like the other teams.
But it is pretty.
It's a huge map.
Oh my gosh.
There's still more?
God.
There's more to this map?
Like, oh my god.
Alright, but who's the mid boss though?
So true.
Don't let it be a cat.
It can't be a cat, right?
Maybe a mouse.
Maybe a giant mouse.
I like that.
Tom and Jerry style.
Look at the chandelier.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Wait, I see it.
Crazy.
You don't even look up really when you're playing, but it's so beautiful.
You've got all the details and stuff.
We went all out with this one.
This is a really cool matchup.
Right, so if I had to describe these, Minecraft analysis mode on.
Okay, analyzer go.
We have... Team SmallAnt is mostly speedrunners.
And that's why I think I know them so well.
I'm really good friends with most of the guys on that team.
That's why they're speeding through a lot of the games too.
And they've been winning super fast, right?
It kind of fits their brand.
But on the other team, it's Team Lifesteal.
Now, most of these guys are on a server together, which is all about PvP.
They love, you know, the whole thing is killing each other and trying to steal each other's life.
That's why it's called Lifesteal.
So, if I had to be honest, I think that Hanna's team is going to be stronger in the combat side of things.
But it's weird because in some of the games that we've been watching, Hanna's team has had less kills.
So maybe they're trying to focus on strategy.
But I know that the speedrunner guys, they know how to... they know the ins and outs of this game.
I'm sure they've checked the meta.
They know exactly what's the best.
I'm pretty sure they researched a hell of a lot.
Exactly.
And, I mean, I think that it's pretty telling that these guys are in the final.
I know that individually, amongst the teams, they're really good friends as well.
Like, all five of the teams, they have good synergy.
They have good communications.
They're able to give advice and listen and talk really easily.
And maybe that wasn't true for some of the other teams.
And that's why we see these two in the final.
Dude, I'm just excited, okay?
I love these teams.
I'm so hyped.
Because they've been playing together in all these Minecraft tournaments for a long time now.
So the chemistry must be, like, really tight by now.
Yeah, this isn't their first rodeo.
They've played these games before.
Team Hanna just needs to be more bloodthirsty maybe.
Maybe.
I think that Team Hanna are better at the combat stuff, so maybe they do need to use it to their advantage.
Hanna might win via tie.
True, possibly.
Because, like, Hanna's team is better when the games draw on longer.
Because they're really good at defense, what I've noticed.
Just because they literally just depend on one person for offense.
True, and the SmallAnts team are much more attacking.
They go way faster.
Yeah, they really do.
It depends on, like, if the game draws on too long or not.
Because, like, the thing is, though, the thing is, though, like, Hanna and Sparkle's team was a very close match.
It was, right?
But SmallAnts demolished Sparkle's team.
It sounds like they got through that match a lot faster, right?
Yeah, they did.
They apparently got the first tower within five minutes, which is crazy.
Yeah, that's insane.
I really want to know how important that middle boss is for these winners.
I know that the matches that we've watched, sometimes that GumGum or the equivalent...
GumGum or...
ForeverGumGum?
I'm not even calling it MidBoss.
It's GumGum.
Exactly.
I don't know how important that GumGum is, right?
Is it crucial or is it just kind of a distraction?
It's the money, right?
It's more money.
So, like, that means they get more upgrades for it faster.
But then, like, will it work for them to their advantage with having a head start with the money situation?
Because you can't just farm creep to match it.
Yeah, like, maybe they don't even attack the MidBoss and they're just going for these zombies and these little mobs around the outside.
Is it equivalent?
Is it better?
I'm sure that these top two teams have their strategies locked down.
They know exactly what they want to do.
They've already played, like, what, four games already?
Like, they better have their strategies locked down by then.
I think both of these teams have played four games and they've won all four.
So, both of them are undefeated going into this final match.
For the middle, for the GumGumBoss, the winner gets 300 coins on killing that guy.
That is pretty good.
We haven't seen really anyone getting, I feel, any armor upgrades.
At least they're not visual.
I think it's, like, I don't think it's a visual thing, I'm pretty sure.
I think it's, like, I think it's just, like, as long as you...
otherwise it's cosmetics.
Yeah, all those coins can really impact all the upgrades.
Like, 300 coins is a lot of coins in general.
Have you seen teams one without it, though?
You can go from a diamond sword to a netherite sword with 450 coins, so, you know, it's like...
Oh, that's a lot, yeah.
So, you know, that's pretty big.
Wait, is that the midboss, the oracle?
Nah, that's not fun.
Wait, I didn't see him.
Yeah, it's just...
It's like a...
Devs, you heard that?
Change it.
Right now.
It's meow meow mana, hello?
Like, the enemy should be a mouse.
Look at the little mice that are fighting the little mom mice.
Oh, they're all mice?
Okay, cool.
Yeah, but the...
Oh my god, that already got some pp, okay.
Oh, they got...
And Feinberg gets one back.
It's one killer piece for these guys so far.
Dude, that's a hundred coins for the witch?
That's a really good strategy.
It looks like these guys might know.
Wait, you just kill three witches and it'll be over.
Oh...
Feinberg getting 3v1'd, he cannot handle that.
Pyromaniac, pangy.
Blue team is just traveling in a group and stuff, trying to catch them.
I think they know that red team is mostly all solos, trying to farm as much as they can individually.
So they're trying to catch them off guard.
Especially with the map so big.
How important are those kills, though?
How important does that even matter?
Or does that, like...
I think Silva's just going for coins there so a death isn't really that important, I feel.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe this is gonna be huge.
True, of course.
I feel like it's not worth it because, I mean, maybe the first death or two but after that they gotta be really careful because the timer keeps increasing.
Exactly.
Oh my god, there they go.
They're going for the oracle.
The oracle.
It's like a giant square.
Oh, that is quite cool, to be fair.
That's pretty cool.
It's just a giant square.
No, it looks like that one thing.
The beam thing?
Yeah, the beam thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Minecraft and now this guy.
What is the beam thing?
Oh, it's a beacon, right?
Oh, the beacon, yeah!
See, that's why we have you here.
That's what I'm here for.
What's the technical term?
The scientific term of this creature?
Yeah, the scientific term of this Minecraft item.
We already see Hanna's team being very aggressive, so...
Yeah, this has been the most aggressive I've ever seen Hanna's team.
I think that's what they need to do.
I think that's the right strategy for them because they are stronger when it comes to combat.
You can see Shratta is probably going to take out...
Is that Rattles?
I think that's Rattles.
Oh, Rattles got the 2v1!
Come on, Rad!
He barely lost any HP for that, too.
That's my goat right there.
He was like half HP from biases on the table.
Okay, okay.
Sorry, my fault.
I shouldn't be biased.
You should head... Oh wait, no.
He's not CaptainSparklez.
I was going to say you should head over there and interrupt them coming in, but that's not CaptainSparklez.
Hey, he's in the third place playoff.
I gotta keep a track on that.
If he wins the third place playoff, I'm running in there and jumping on him.
It depends on how long that match goes on for.
Maybe we'll be able to see it if TeamSquadLand is able to speed run their way out of this, but it looks like the blue team are getting a lot of kills.
But to be fair, they're always 2v1ing.
I don't see... They lose the 1v1 but they win majority of the 2v1s.
Yeah, that's true.
Rattles was able to take one of those 2v1s, but most of them you're right, they're going in the direction of Hannah's team.
They're all grouping up and stuff.
Hannah's team is just grouping up for kills, while SmallAnt's team is all like, they're all so separated and split up.
Two reds though.
Two reds pushing in on Kaboodle here.
I don't know if she's going to be able to hold them off here.
Oh, she gets silver.
Oh, she got one of them.
Oh, she got two!
She gets both!
Damn, these 1v2s are crazy!
I don't know.
SmallAnt's team is going to keep accumulating deaths.
It's going to be rough for them.
Maybe they're getting a lot of coins right now.
We don't know.
We can't tell about the currency and the mana and stuff.
So maybe they're just farming creep, like you say.
Yeah, but like getting kills also gives you gold I assume.
True, you're probably right.
I'm pretty sure.
Majority of MOBAs is like that.
I'm pretty sure getting kills is also very important as well.
And if you get kills on late game, you get more gold.
Feinberg, she's behind you!
Hanna's behind you!
Oh!
I wonder if you can hear their footsteps.
Dude, I've got a live feed to Feinberg's ear.
What the heck?
How did he know?
Oh my god, he got the kill.
I wonder if you can't hear the footsteps very well.
Or like, they have an ability to mute the footsteps.
I know that these speedrunners have definitely got... you know when you first start the game, he comes up and says like turn this on for narrator so it like speaks out what it is you're doing.
There's another accessibility setting that gives you subtitles.
Oh yeah, that went on.
So you can see the footsteps and maybe that was what he used there.
In that corner you're able to see, oh, footsteps behind you.
Oh, that means there's a person there.
Maybe he's able to use that.
Does everyone not play with the subtitles on?
I feel like that's essential.
I think that's smart to do.
Like, I definitely play with them on.
I don't know, but these guys probably just started with a new...
Oh, Feinberg takes a death.
Wait, I think that's Feinberg's ult, right?
I think that might have been Pangy's.
Yeah.
Pangy's the fire guy.
No, no, he didn't ult.
No, it was...
Wait, what?
That was Feinberg?
That was an item or ability.
Maybe it was one of the lower tier ones.
Yeah, the abilities, right?
They still got abilities and ults.
That's another kill for Hanna's team.
They've just been killing non-stop.
I know, it's kind of... I haven't seen any kills from small...
Oh, I mean, there's one right now, but like I feel like the majority of the kills were on Hanna's team.
Yeah.
They're not letting them farm.
They're not letting them like...
They're increasing their time to come back, so it's...
This is smart.
It's elongating the game as well, which we've seen.
Hanna's team's doing so much better in those longer games.
Yeah.
They're able to farm a lot more, get more coins, get more advantage.
I think if these teams are evenly matched, I'd always back blue team.
I'd back Hanna's team in just a raw 1v1.
Because I think their combat skills are much better.
Yeah, they did it.
Judging, looking at this, yeah.
I honestly thought like...
I thought that Feinberg's team was gonna like, just like roll over them, but like they're making a very evenly match right now.
And we've seen in previous matches that SmallAnt's team goes in very quickly, and they don't have a chance to here.
Like it's... No damage.
No damage at all.
We would see them like get towers in.
But now like they haven't yet.
Which is interesting.
Well maybe the Oracle is gonna swing it in red team's favor.
If they're able to get a few kills here, and then maybe take out that mid boss, maybe they'll be able to come back and start farming some better gear.
I think that if that's not gonna be the case, if blue take out this mid boss... Blue is getting the Oracle right now.
Look out below!
Red team were able to kind of avoid that stun though.
Oh dude!
Look at how quickly they're taking out the damage though!
Hannah's destroying!
I think that's her ultimate.
Oh but Hannah dies!
If red team can crit it out right now, and there's no there's no one to defend it.
Oh run back!
Come on!
Silver!
And Silver takes it out!
That's my underdog right there.
That's my hidden gem.
It's all that matter.
All of the coins.
That was a good example of the ult though.
It looked like he was using a macro there.
I know!
It looked like that cookie clicker macro.
Now I think it's pretty even.
Red have got... Red can get so many upgrades now.
What are you trying to say?
What are you trying to confess?
I don't know.
So Red got the upgrades but nothing is happening so far.
I don't know how important those upgrades are but Red gets another kill there as well.
Apparently my chat said it's like a whole entire upgrade for a team.
So like it actually does a lot but I think like... Yeah 300 coins could definitely get you... Yeah 300 coins would get you from sharpness 1 to sharpness 2 which that's more important than a single upgrade individually.
Because like a sharpness 2 iron sword is better than a sharpness 1 diamond sword so that's massive actually.
I like how his teammate just ignored him.
Oh there he goes.
He's like Oh!
He turned around way too late.
Finally we're seeing some tower damage and Blue's tower is getting damaged here.
So Red are taking attack here.
Just a little bit.
Just a chip but you know it's something.
10 minutes in.
Hey anything is helpful at this point.
I know yeah.
In 2 minutes all the towers are gonna get damaged.
Yeah I was gonna say at this point it's it's gonna be anyone's game honestly.
Yeah it's weight is really close.
It definitely gets much more much more exciting when all the towers get damaged.
Then it's like really quick to destroy a tower at that point.
It gets super duper close.
I mean these teams are pretty much neck and neck right now.
They've not lost their game for the whole time.
I love that.
I love that we're seeing the best of the best play against each other.
Yeah.
And right now I honestly thought maybe one team would have already won.
Or one team would have been at least significantly ahead.
But there's no real huge advantage.
Sure red have a little bit of damage.
But that can be done in 2 seconds by blue team.
I think they could easily make this comeback.
I'm so interested to see Hannah's team's player kill count.
Oh my god.
Hannah's team's just been killing everybody.
I'm curious how many kills their entire team has had so far.
Like I barely see red team getting the kills at the moment.
But they're still really close.
I think it's just cause like...
I think it's just cause like even if they're killing a lot... if blue team's killing a lot of them, someone in red team is farming a lot of gold for everybody.
Cause like I feel like with the amount of people that...
Oh my god.
There they go.
Oh nice.
We got a little bit of the...
Like a fraction of the heart I think.
Yeah.
I just feel like...
Cause like I feel like with the amount of people that blue team's been killing, they should be like overrunning them.
But yet they're like...
They seem like similar...
Like similar skill wise and gold wise.
Oh the hiding...
The hide strat.
Oh!
What?
The boat?
Where did that come from?
Wait, there's a boat?
Yeah!
Who was that?
Feinberg?
He just pulled out a boat.
He's gonna run people over with a boat.
What does a boat even do?
Oh, there's another fight?
Oh, they lost the fight.
Oh, that's my...
Oh gosh.
I think if they take small land out, they can like go for the towers at that point.
I think...
Both teams have some damage here.
The biggest disadvantage is also this map is huge.
It's so big.
I feel like by the time they get to the tower people would have already respawned too.
Oh no!
I think that was Feinberg.
I mean, it's a 1v2.
Oh, it's a 1v3.
He's like, I'm gonna kill you.
I think someone pulled off.
Yeah, I think they're...
You can see another person heading in for it.
Feinberg's trying to distract.
ADHD kicking in.
No, I think it's good to go after the witches though because they're big money.
They're big money but it's just funny to see they're like, witching.
Fighting, I'm fighting.
Oh, a witch.
Oh, silver.
Hannah is strong.
She's scary.
A witch.
The witches seem like they're pretty overpowered.
You get 100 coins if you kill one.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
Three witches equals an oracle.
Yeah.
So that's why it's worth going after them.
Yeah, that's why he's like, a witch.
Oh, a witch.
gold you... I guess it depends on how late game it is.
I was wondering how much gold you get for like, player kills.
No, we don't really...
Do we see that?
Does that pop up when they...
I don't know.
Because like, it'd be...
You do get gold, right?
For killing players?
Because usually MOBAs, you get gold for killing players.
Yeah, I think we get gold and aura per kill.
Yeah, because it depends on... The more late game it is, the more gold you get because it's more upgraded and stuff.
These guys are hoarding their ults.
Look, four ults for team red and the blue team, so close as well.
Oh my god, he just 1v2'd.
Oh, apparently it's plus 25 gold for players.
Oh, so there's no point in killing players.
I mean, there is a point, but like, I mean, there's a point, but like, you get more gold from...
Oh, red!
We've seen it before and he's gonna do it again.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, they took him down.
But it's worth it.
Oh, they're getting one too.
Nice.
Okay, we got some action going on.
Oh my god, look how fast he is though.
All three towers have just a bit of damage taken.
Yeah, but that red team's tower is almost down though.
It's like 25%.
I feel like there's more damage...
Oh my god.
Who was it?
Who was it that...
What's his name?
The guy that did the other tower?
What?
Shatter?
Shatter's damage is insane compared to the others.
Yeah.
He almost got that tower to half HP while like... Just by himself.
Yeah, just by himself.
Oh.
Versus like the red team trying to do the same thing.
Because I think it was Finebird that tried to take the tower and he only got like a little bit of the percentage off.
Hmm.
This is a really long game.
And like we said at the start, the longer games are gonna be favoring Team Blue, but look at Team Red here.
Oh my god.
One on each tower.
Oh, they're all respawning.
Oh my god.
That's one tower down.
Two towers down.
And there's all the respawns coming in.
Four respawns.
No one's getting silver.
They all have ults.
Wow.
But that's a lot of damage.
That was huge.
Wait, when did they kill three?
They almost got a crystal too.
Wait, wait, wait.
The one guy.
I think one guy's gonna take down the one tower.
Oh.
But they almost got two crystals out of that though from the Red team.
When did they kill three?
I didn't even notice that.
Three of them were down.
That was a huge push.
Yeah.
That was a huge push from Red team.
I didn't even notice.
Oh, which?
I didn't even notice that.
You don't have to.
I'm gonna kill you.
Shatter is truly a...
He is a menace.
He's like, get over here.
I'm gonna have rabbit stew.
I'm hearing a lot of shouts from my current next door neighbor.
I think it's positive.
He's cheering.
I don't think he's won yet.
Look at all the towers took damage.
They're half damage now.
Oh my god, the half time.
That kind of evens it back up, right?
Yeah, it does.
Pretty much.
It felt like Red was heavily in the lead and now the lead is being cut by quite a lot.
That's where the RNG kicks in.
No, it's all skill.
I thought that witch was someone coming for backup.
Nope.
No time to go after the witch right now.
He got the crystal.
Even though he died, he got the crystal.
And there's a big...
That's the tower down.
Rattles gets the tower down.
Rattles gets the 1v1.
Dude, she got it down to 1 HP.
Yeah, Smalllands not gonna do a lot of damage here, but is drawing out a lot of players.
Can he get one hit off maybe?
One hit on a crystal?
Two hits?
Okay.
That's helpful.
That, they're just...
The crystals are literally like one hit away from...
Oh my god, the spawn time is a lot longer now.
Is it like 20 seconds?
But to be fair, the map's so big by the time they get there.
They're basically respawning.
Yeah, exactly.
Look out below!
Oh, the oracle's back alive.
I guess someone could take out that mid-boss, but it's kind of useless at this point.
I feel like it's not worth it.
It's definitely not worth it for Team Red, who only have to kill like one tiny little crystal.
And Feinberg uses his ult!
And a lot of damage comes out!
Crystals down!
Dragon!
This is gonna be it.
Feinberg's trying to defend the respawns.
Defending the respawns as best as he can.
10 HP!
It's over!
And it's over!
Team Snorlamp takes the victory!
Oh my god!
Look at that!
Everybody in Blue Team was dead!
And I couldn't even take out the last tower.
Like, wow!
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
That was a crazy game.
It was so close, too.
Oh my gosh.
It's crazy to see, because Hanna's team basically... I felt like Hanna's team did so well in kills, but I'm pretty sure, like... I'm pretty sure Red Team was legit just farming creeps.
They didn't care about player kills.
That was crazy.
Which is so interesting, because it feels like that's exactly what Hanna's team did for the rest of the game.
They had less kills in a lot of these games, but in this one, Hanna's team got so many kills, but it didn't really help.
This was such an important moment, where they were able to take out the Oracle in the middle.
This round, Team Smolett has 54 kills, and Team Hanna had 35.
What?
Wait, what?
Smolett got more kills?
I guess so.
I guess we just didn't see it.
Maybe the view we had was... I don't know.
Maybe it was like the spectator.
Yeah.
We just didn't see some of the side kills or something.
That's crazy.
It felt like Hanna was killing everybody.
It felt like that, right?
Maybe it was more so in the beginning, too.
They might be getting kills at endgame, because you know how they were 1v3ing, and we saw those 1v3 kills.
Yeah, I think late game, they definitely got more kills, but we didn't see them, but beginning, it was all like we just saw Hanna's team killing everybody in the beginning.
Oh my god.
It truly is... You can't call the game so early, you know?
It's anybody's game.
Yeah, yeah.
But I was right in my prediction.
That's my Oshi!
Woo!
I'll show you some biases right now.
No!
Well, I guess we have almost everybody.
Team Sparklez did win against Team 5up.
Okay, you definitely didn't hear me celebrating that.
I don't want to hear it.
You guys didn't hear me...
Yeah, he got there in the end.
Oh, wow.
Even the overall kills and everything.
Oh my god, small with 264 overall kills.
Wow.
That's the highest out of everyone, too.
Most overall wins and highest overall kills, like wow.
That's a lot, yeah.
They just swept.
The second team was 231 kills.
That was...
Yeah, Team TMC.
Yeah, but still 264.
That is a lot of kills.
What is that?
Over 4 games?
5 games is that?
5 different games and that's 264 kills?
Yeah.
That's so many.
Within 5 games?
That's so much for 5 games in general.
Which is very crazy to see.
We're still waiting on one more team or one more match.
One final match.
Yeah.
Who's the last final match?
It's Team Snifferish versus Team Shubble.
Oh, beautiful.
Look at this.
We get to see the rematches.
Gum Gum!
We love you, Gum Gum!
Yeah.
If Gum Gum had a concert, I would be there.
Bring back Gum.
Replace all the Mii Boss with Gum Gum.
Honestly.
Give the people what they want.
In the next MCL, you aren't gonna have any Minecraft Pro Analysis because I'm gonna be there and I'm gonna just be protecting Gum Gum the whole time.
I'm not even gonna be trying.
I'm gonna be surrounding Gum Gum.
Yep, that's it.
I'm telling you.
I'm making it out the trenches.
Gum Gum bodyguard.
You gotta get through the VTuber casting to get in the tournament.
This was your test.
This was his test.
And once again...
It's just because they can't have two Captain Sparkles in the tournament.
True.
Only one Captain Sparkles per tournament.
No British allowed.
We should have like a whole Sparkles team.
Captain Sparkles.
Major Sparkles.
I like how you said Major Sparkles before British Sparkles.
Admiral Sparkles.
Private Sparkles.
Yeah, exactly.
That's the Gum Gum guard.
The Gum Gum guard.
The Sparkle guard.
Which was your favorite map, Doki?
I think... Oh, that's hard.
I think I like Gum Gum.
That map was unique because it was like really, you know...
There's high ground and low ground.
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, it was big with the low ground stuff but I feel like... I think the last map was huge.
There's so much going on.
Huge.
I feel bad for the spectators.
Computers, the render distance is maxed out.
There's so many things to look at, too.
There's so many things happening at the same time, so it's hard to capture.
There were tunnels, too, for the last map.
There were so many things going on.
Maybe that's why we missed some of the kills because obviously Team Smallland ended up getting more kills than Team Hanna, but...
It could have been also late game.
Yeah, 100% believe it was a lot of late game kills, too.
I guess that creep really helped Team Smallland.
Getting that mid boss was able to get them a load of upgrades.
And there it is.
Team won!
Wow!
There it is!
That was pretty... That was a clean kill, too.
At the end.
That was pretty exciting to be our first co-casting in Minecraft tournament.
Sorry, trio casting.
Oh yeah, trio.
Thank you!
Analysis expert.
Hey, that's me.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah!
Thanks for giving us the analysis and telling us what was going on, too.
In a more professional manner.
I know.
I'm just trying to help you guys out and make sure that everyone understands what's going on whenever I can.
Thank you guys for having me.
I'm jealous, man.
You guys got these little VTubers.
Look at you.
You're dancing around.
You can technically dance around.
Yeah!
I have been.
I've been sitting here.
I've had my webcam on the whole time just so that I could pretend I was on the screen.
For who?
Literally for me.
Ah!
Flash!
That's so funny.
Oh my god.
It literally...
I felt like Five Nights at Freddy's jump scare.
British jump scare.
Oh my god.
Flash bang.
I wasn't expecting that.
That was amazing.
Oh my god.
What a jump scare.
I almost got a little afraid that we're going to go 3D for a while.
No, relax.
It's okay.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready to be in 2D form for a little longer.
That was fun.
I had a great time co-casting or trio casting with all of you guys.
Thank you for inviting us.
Thank you for having us.
Congrats to Team Small Land!
If we ever have any speedrun...
If we ever do another speedrun hardcore we'll come to you for advice.
I will be there no matter what.
I promise you.
I will be there.
Don't watch.
I'm going to ban you from my channel.
I'm not allowed to watch anymore.
We will be in Minecraft a second time.
I believe in you guys.
Just don't watch us.
I'll close my eyes.
I'll listen.
You need to do this next.
Don't even listen.
I'm not going to ban at 0%.
Fine.
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay.
We just don't want you to steal our strats.
I can't.
We have some of our own secret strats.
We don't want that exposed to the world.
I think you guys are a bit too good.
If I tried to copy your strats, I think you'd win.
Here, I'll get you in on a secret.
One of them is to just kill yourself if you don't feel the vibe.
That's true.
You know what the crazy thing is?
That's actually a real strat as well.
I'll tell you about that another time.
Oh my god.
I believe you.
Do you have anything else you'd like to say?
No, I just want to say a massive thank you to you two.
It's been an amazing vibe.
I've been over the moon being able to jump around, talk around with you guys.
You guys have brought the absolute most hype that we've ever seen to a Minecraft event, I think.
We need to have more casters that are like you guys.
Just excited and shit.
It's been awesome!
I love that.
It's been so exciting.
If there was three of me, it wouldn't work, right?
I'd just be yapping about statistics.
Oh my god, can we have three British people?
Right?
You needed to balance me out and I loved it.
It was a great balance, so thank you guys for having me on.
I've absolutely loved it.
Yeah, thanks for all the analysis.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But also, I think you were supposed to say something too.
Oh, am I supposed to say something?
One more shout out.
Yeah, okay, sorry.
That was my segue for you.
Dude, you can try your best, but more importantly, shout out to you two.
But also, thank you very much to H&R Block for making amazing things happen in gaming.
Woo!
Make sure to go to Lunar Client and check out the free HRB cosmetics.
And remember, with H&R Block, it's better with Block.
Thank you guys.
Woo!
Remember to use exclamation point Lunar in both Min and I's chat to see more details about it.
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
That is so real.